Music
and
Hi!
Wait, what do you mean, you know, I need to show you guys the eating big butts.
Yeah, like, we were discussing before Stream started that guinea pigs don't have tails,
and I'm like, nah, you're lying.
No, they don't have tails!
Oh my god, they do have butt cramps!
What is this?
Wait, are you serious?
Is this real?
Is this a photoshopped?
Is this photoshopped?
Why is it like concave?
It looks like those frogs with butts.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
It's, um, I believe it's called a grease gland.
I don't like a grease gland.
That's where all the grease is made.
That just doesn't look real to me.
It's like my brain doesn't accept that.
I know, same.
I'm just like, where's the tail?
Is that your guinea pig?
No, I do own guinea pigs, but that's why I knew they don't have tails.
Oh, okay.
I know this is your butt, though.
It's my butt.
Oh my god, look at the little feet.
They have little rat peats.
They are very rat-like.
Oh my god.
I'm allergic to guinea pigs and rodents.
You should be honestly fine with guinea pigs.
I think guinea pigs are pretty good with people who have allergies.
No, I'm allergic to rabbits and I'm allergic to guinea pigs.
Don't ask me why I'm a rabbit and I'm allergic to rabbits.
This is how things are.
Can I ask you why you're allergic to guinea pigs?
Because my friend had a guinea pig.
And I would always get itchy and like, sneeze-y.
That's crazy.
Guinea pigs are like one of the harder animals to be allergic to.
I guess I win that that.
I'm allergic to animals that I wish I could love, but I can't because they make me sneeze.
Honestly.
That's such a shame.
You can't even love yourself.
I know, I can't.
Last time I hung out with a bunny, I almost went into anaphylactic shock.
Oh.
No.
It was again a travesty.
You know, I have a friend with seven cats.
And my roommates like heavily alert cats.
So we go over and even with like air purifiers and it cleaned the place regularly,
it like he dies after like an hour.
Oh no.
Natural selection.
Maybe he's going to kill me.
I'm sorry.
We have to make room for the strong and then she just cuts my head off or something.
I don't know.
She just sticks her out.
I don't know if I'm allergic to rats or mice.
I don't know.
They're not, they're not particularly fluffy creatures.
Are they hard or something?
It's like the spit.
No, but they're soft.
Rats are really soft.
I had a friend who brought them to school.
You touched a rat?
What do you want to say?
Go ahead.
I'm going to say, I'm going to hold my tongue on this one.
Why?
I'm going to hold my tongue on this one.
No, no, go ahead.
Say it.
Go ahead.
No, because I know you're going to bully me later.
No, no, no.
You mean my bully you though?
You mean my bully you?
Say it.
I'm not going to say it.
I mean, don't you own rats?
I do.
Yeah, yeah.
Say it.
No, I'm not trying to get beat up.
I'm not trying to get beat up here.
Self preservation.
She will survive me.
Not so much.
Rats are awesome.
It's like that, it's like that scene from Ben 10 with Kevin.
He's like, you got to treat a woman like you treat your car.
And this girlfriend's like, yeah, go on.
And he's like, no.
It's the way you bring up the scene every time I talk to you.
You know, it's crazy.
Oh, I think it was like, honestly, seven year old me, whatever,
whatever they had, they came out with like teen Ben 10.
I thought Kevin was so hot.
Because he was.
You're not wrong.
Kevin who?
Who?
Mr. Kevin.
Let me use the ultimate zoomer.
Kevin 11.
Wait.
I think it's Kevin 11.
Yeah.
Kevin 11.
He has like a car.
Yeah.
No, no, no, no.
Okay, okay.
There's like an ugly version of him now.
Wait, I want to see, how did this age, because I haven't seen the show yet.
No, no, okay.
Wait, yeah.
So there's like, there's an ugly one where it kind of looks like a stoner.
And he does not look good, but like.
Yeah.
But there's like.
Oh yeah.
No, not him.
No.
I feel like we're being.
It was a different version.
No, I think I see the version you mean.
Yeah.
Okay.
There we go.
The black t-shirt and the gray.
Yeah.
That's the one.
Okay.
That's the hotline.
I see what you mean.
You're judging us.
I was really judging you for the first picture I saw.
I was like.
Because he was fine back in the day.
Oh, it was like the alien.
No, no, no, no, no.
Maybe, maybe you live like alien.
Yeah.
Four arms is hot.
Okay.
Maybe we should start the game.
Or we should introduce ourselves.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, I just think everyone knew, but that's my bad.
Not everyone knows.
It's okay.
We can, we can.
Because the only people that matter are the four people in this call and we love each other.
That's right.
Maybe.
Someone asked, are these the friends?
What's wrong with that?
What do you mean are these the friends?
Of course they're my friends.
The two friends you have, the three.
You not count, right?
Did you, did you, did you say to myself?
Yeah.
Because we're really.
Oh.
She's more than a friend.
She's my wife.
Your twin flame.
We could have been roommates.
Do you guys think, so what is a twin flame?
Is that like a soulmate?
It's a cult.
What?
No.
It's a cult.
Really?
No, no, no.
That's something else in me.
No.
A twin flame is usually someone that you're meant to have a relationship and within a
karmic cycle and it's very hot and burning and it can actually be pretty toxic, but
very passionate and loving at the same time.
Oh, so me and Viv.
It's like a shitty soulmate.
A shitty soulmate.
Yeah, that's us.
I beat her in game pigeon and then I laugh at her.
I hate her so much.
Okay, to be fair, I was going to go easy on her and then she said, you're going down.
Oh.
I thought you would like that.
I thought that would make it hotter for you.
So we played eight ball and she made fun of me for a bad play and then she immediately
hit the eight ball into the hole and she lost in the first round.
I didn't know how eight ball works.
I didn't know like you literally couldn't touch the eight ball.
I didn't know.
It was unlucky for me.
We should probably introduce ourselves.
Sorry, I'm reading my chat because they're like, wait, isn't that like in the, like a
Will Smith movie in Hancock?
And I totally forgot that that is part of that movie.
What is it?
The Twin Flames something or other.
But it is a cult.
Yeah.
I only know the cult one.
It's all you need to know.
Okay.
Hi, hi, hi everyone.
Hi chat.
Um, I'm, I'm Emmy.
I'm from Vealer.
Uh, yeah.
Nice to meet you.
Yeah.
That's fair.
Who wants to go next?
If no one raises their hand, I'm going to choose.
Okay.
All in told.
Um, hi.
Hello there.
My name is Sheebie Cottonbum of Gen 1 Vealers Indulge.
And I'm your favorite dorky girl failure, Dom failure.
What?
She already fucked it up.
Yeah.
Good job, Sheebie.
I tried my best.
Viv, do you want to go first?
You want me?
Yeah.
Okay.
I guess I'll go.
Hi.
I'm Vivian Voss, your neighborhood biker babe.
Nice to meet you.
You're a biker.
Yeah.
Like, like a tricycle?
She doesn't even know what to say.
She just stared at the camera like, what the fuck did you just say?
I need to take a really big breath after that one.
I was, I have anger management issues.
Baby girl.
She was having like flashbacks to something else.
I wanted to know it's a unicycle.
Okay.
She's the only human.
Wait, actually no, Amy's human.
I'm human.
Are you human?
I thought you were like a, what was it called?
A gamer.
I hate you.
I have a different race.
I'm a gamer.
I mean, look at that dick.
You guys didn't know this, but we were in call and we were talking about something completely
different.
And then I just went, why do you have a dent in your head?
And I never noticed him.
He has a lovely cute dent in her head.
I can rest my booba in it.
Maybe that's why it's dented.
Cause it's only dented on her.
I actually kind of want that as a photo.
Me just like picking her up and tucking her under my breast.
This is holding her closely to my bosom.
Okay.
I was like that too.
All right.
So am I the only one who's played this before?
I haven't done my intro.
Oh, I'm leaving.
I'm just going to be down here.
I'm just proud to also not a softy.
I'm a guinea pig.
I have a nice butt apparently.
That's it.
We didn't say nice.
I know.
I have a nice butt.
Confounding.
I mean, it's a butt.
All right.
Something.
Okay.
I don't have a tail.
I mean, your butt hangs kind of low.
You got a long back or something like that.
Oh, are you talking about, are you talking about like her guinea pig butt?
Oh, okay.
She's just mad.
I said she rides a bicycle.
A tricycle.
Oh, a tricycle.
Yeah.
I really hate me.
Okay.
We should start this game before she kills me.
I'm starting it.
Has anybody played the game?
I'm in the back.
Oh, hold on.
We have played before.
Viv is going to kill us.
Wait, who's in the middle?
Okay.
So we got Emmy and Sopralto on the ends.
Very interesting.
Uh-oh.
Emmy.
Emmy, what?
No, you might.
I actually think I trust you more than Sopralto.
What?
I'll have you know.
I am broke even though you've never played before.
Is the end like an important task?
See, the gods are mad at you for that.
There's no god here.
I can pull people?
Oh, I can pull you guys in.
Oh, shit.
I can pull you in.
Oh, pull me in.
I forget how to pull.
How do I pull?
It's easy.
And you look at them.
Are we both an old man?
Yeah.
We're both an old white man.
I specifically chose the old man.
I don't know.
He's pretty spry for being an old guy.
Pretty fly for an old guy.
We have our toes out, too.
We do.
We are barefoot.
What the heck?
No, no, no.
Don't let them look.
That's charge premium.
Okay, cover it with the chains at all times.
It's not too hard so far.
Oh, walking.
So what we said about not trusting me?
Don't do it.
You guys can't see.
See what?
See he's not in your mouth.
Oh my god.
You can't see my game.
How can you not see my game?
Pull me.
You pull me.
I'm pulling you.
Don't worry.
Okay.
It's all in the character selection screen for everyone.
How is that happening?
Did you do capture or were you sure in game capture?
You should do game capture.
Okay.
Now it's working.
I don't know why it did that.
There you go.
Time to lock in.
Is this in difficult mode or do we have technologies?
I put normal mode from what I remember.
Ah!
Okay.
Do you want to have countdown?
No.
We're brought down.
Countdown?
No.
We don't do countdowns around here.
Okay.
We just go for it.
Mine.
Okay.
You know what we kind of look like?
We look like Grunko Stan, Ford, Mabel, and Wendy.
What a redhead.
Oh, you're wrong.
What is that?
Yeah, what is this?
It's from Gravity Falls.
All right.
We'll go in order.
Uh, or not.
It's fine.
We've gotten this far.
I'm just waiting for one of us to fall off.
What is that?
You want me to fall off?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Did you just say fall off?
Well, if you do, we can pull you back up, I guess.
Is that a bet?
No, I would.
I would do it.
Do it.
Throw yourself off.
Don't do it, please.
You have to get it.
Pull it up.
I can't.
You're too heavy.
Grab.
You got to grab.
Oh, sorry.
I can't.
Wait.
No.
Pam.
No!
Wait.
I can't.
I'll just follow you.
I don't believe it.
It's hard.
The
thing is that I think we can, in this case , leave us there.
How did she manage to be a good gamer?
I think we should leave surprise up now, okay?
We should cut her off at the end.
Wait, we're twins, so you can't leave me.
I should have eaten you in the womb.
Don't fall off in the fall.
Was that fall off?
Oh my god.
Do you have selective hearing?
I'm maybe.
I mean, I am an old guy.
You got to adjust your hearing aid, brother.
All right, so don't touch me.
Oh, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Oh, awesome.
OK, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
I'm not going to be pulling salt in you.
I'm going to fall if I turn around.
No, OK, just bolt this back up, back up.
You see that thingy?
What thingy?
The little stick.
Why don't you jump on the other side of the stick,
and then we can, like, jump on the other side of the stick.
Or you can back up on the rock.
I can't jump.
And then press E. OK.
Someone's going to write.
The stream is just too bad.
I'm going to do it first.
OK, there we go.
Can you guys?
Can you come up from here or no?
Can you pull me?
Can I want for you?
Can you come up here for me?
I'm scared.
OK, I'll come in for you.
OK.
Help me, please.
Oh, OK, we did it.
That wasn't too bad.
I can't wait.
We've only gotten this far.
You guys are stupid.
I'm not even at, like, the crazy part yet.
This isn't the crazy part.
Wait, what are you waiting?
This isn't the hardest part.
No, this isn't the hardest part.
Tell me, we haven't even gotten past the tutorial.
No, this is literally still a tutorial.
This is a tutorial?
Essentially.
OK, what?
This kind of gives you a taste of everything.
OK, ready?
So don't touch these.
We have to jump over them.
Can the chain touch it?
Yes, that's fine.
OK.
You can also run.
Don't get hit by that.
Thanks.
And then you can Mario climb the fence.
What does that mean?
Mario climb the fence.
You'll see what I mean.
We've literally played this game before.
What do you mean?
Mario climb the fence.
Someone said we're just two pairs of the same person.
They're kind of right.
You're not wrong, actually.
I was thinking that earlier.
I didn't want to show, but I didn't want to say it.
How do I get off?
Just press B.
All right, OK, so there's a trampoline.
So we're just going to 1, 2, 3.
Yippee-doo.
Oh, what just happened?
All right, no, get off.
Get off of it.
OK, OK, OK, we're all going to get it, right?
Aim towards the other one.
There you go.
OK, OK.
Yippee.
OK, OK, OK.
Nice.
I know, go, go, go.
Keep going, make it, make it.
Nice.
Don't worry, Amy, we got you.
I'm stressing.
OK.
Now let's go through the climb.
Now we're going the hole.
The hole.
The love.
The love climb the hole.
I love you, baby girl.
I love you too.
Yeah, pookie.
Pookie?
Pookie bear.
No, that's only for me, babe.
That's only for me.
Earth?
OK, I know for a fact we're going to fall off this time.
No, no, no, no, no, no, I got this.
I got this.
OK, you go first.
You go first.
I don't trust her.
Don't do it.
You're making me nervous.
OK, OK, OK, OK, OK.
I didn't know if it would auto whatever.
It doesn't.
Which way do I go?
Do I go this way?
Use your heart, I trust you.
Are you saying that's because I'm Asian?
What?
No.
I used my heart.
I thought you were a guinea pig.
Exactly.
I can be both.
Ginea pigs can't be Asian.
You still can.
Are they Asian breeds of guinea pigs?
No, but you know, cuppy bars are loved by all of Asia.
So if you think about it, it's kind of like close enough.
That's true.
They are pretty, they are the biggest guinea pig.
Cuppy bars are the largest rodents.
Really?
Probably not.
They have like bristle hairs.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's kind of like a broom.
I think we go this way.
Have you ever touched a cuppy bar?
No, but I'm going on in October to Japan.
I'm going to go touch one.
I'm going to see them in the onsen.
I'm going to touch it.
I'm going to pet it.
You're going to join the cuppy bar a suit?
Are we still going to a cuppy bar?
No, I don't think we're allowed to.
If I could have with them.
You can't bathe with them?
What's the point?
Hold on, hold on.
Did you know that they poop in the water?
Oh, OK.
Yeah, so do I.
And?
That's way past.
In the water that you bathed in me?
Wait, that's why there's that flutter in the pool?
That's why there's that flutter in the pool?
Crazy.
Where are you?
She took us the long way.
Well, I didn't know there was another direction on my bed.
You know you're fine.
I'm just teasing you.
Wait, there's a short way?
Someone say short?
Like you?
I'm not short.
I'm taller than you.
No, you're not.
Well, how tall are you?
5'2".
I'm 5'3".
No way.
I'm 5'3", so this is my dick.
Wow.
It's my balls.
You think that 1 inch saves you?
Yeah, the 1 inch to figure, the 1 inch to figure.
The 1 inch to figure, the 1 inch to figure.
Oh my god, look at that.
Look at that monster.
He's wearing a goat's head monster?
Yeah, a monster over here.
Let's go over here.
He has a long ass tongue.
Oh, is that a tongue?
I think he has a tongue.
He's got a tongue, yeah.
I think he's going to zoom in.
There's a way to do it.
I can't remember how, though.
Is it tilde?
Tilde to zoom in.
No, it's not tilde.
I think that's to bring up the console, isn't it?
How do you zoom in?
Stop this.
What Emmy needs to figure out is how to spawn us when we fall off,
because we can restart at little checkpoint places.
Oh, we can?
No, we're raw dogging it.
You want to start raw dog this?
That means you can't fail.
We have to do it all in one go.
Which way do we go from here?
Remember that time I was playing with you,
and you kept saying stuff about, wait, we found this spot.
Oh, OK, Emmy, it looks like we're going, Emmy.
It looks like we're going, Emmy.
He doesn't jump on the rock.
He said, where are we going?
And I said, we're off.
He said, you're like, OK.
None of us made it long to go.
Please pull me off.
No, no, no, no.
Oh, shit.
No.
You guys are saying that we do this all in one go?
You guys are saying about that respawn.
Let's all agree that this was Emmy's fault.
None of us are ready to go yet.
I was talking.
I jumped on the rock.
I didn't say jump.
You asked me, where are we going?
And I said, we're going to that rock.
OK, so I went to the right.
Wait, this way.
Wait, but how do we respawn?
Tell me the button.
I honestly don't know.
I think Apollo did it.
How are you going to tease us with it and not let us do it?
Wait, hold on.
Let me look it up, then.
I think it's like, I think the way it's done is something like you.
You press a button.
It's in the menu, right?
Oh, it's a button?
Well, I think it's, I don't know.
I'm just guessing.
There is a button that you press.
Are you making out with me, but I'm your sibling?
Self-sist.
What's that?
My friend Hachi would be totally into that.
Huki, are you eating on me?
Identical twin old man.
We have a friend Hachi.
And Hachi loves Genji Exonzo.
And we make fun of it.
I don't blame her.
What?
I think I'm traumatized again.
You're always not allowed to watch.
566 meters?
No.
I don't think we got that far.
I'm sorry.
I'm playing on normal mode.
There's no checkpoints on normal mode.
I told you.
All right.
I think it's raw dogging it.
I don't think this counts as a fall because that was our tutorial.
You know, we had to warm up first.
Warm up.
Guys, we are going to.
OK.
Hachi will never live that down.
Nope.
She traumatized me, and now she's stuck with it.
I'm on the pause menu, then teleport at the center of the screen.
But we are in normal mode.
It doesn't have.
Sorry.
I thought I didn't want to be a scrub and choose easy mode,
you know?
No, we're gamers.
We're gamers.
We got this.
We're stinky.
We're gamers.
Of course.
I shower.
I don't know about you.
Well, you shower every four days.
That still means I shower.
Is that a problem?
How often do you shower?
Oh, we could take the shortcut to the right.
That's a shortcut?
Yeah.
Is it?
Go for it.
Yeah.
OK.
Sure.
I didn't know this was a shortcut.
Me neither.
Why didn't we do this the first time?
Because I didn't see the first time.
I was just following you all.
Look, we did it.
We did it.
The pros already.
Short cut nothing to it.
I wonder how far.
I hope we get to at least to the car.
There's a car?
We've gotten to the car?
No.
See, she like rage quit.
Last time we played it.
Who rage quit?
You.
Not even two hours and she all test fours.
I may have done that.
You can just move your mouse and like slowly turn it as you walk.
No, I'm too nervous.
No, we're speed running there.
Someone's slowing us down here.
Yeah, it's freaky.
I'm too scared to move forward.
They want to fall off.
Beautiful.
I'll catch you.
Don't worry.
Thanks.
You'll catch me?
I'll catch you.
Wait, so who's seen Gravity Falls here?
Me.
I've seen a little bit of it.
I found out the other days that apparently Mabel was supposed to die.
In the show and Disney said no.
I would say no too.
Mabel's really cute.
I love Mabel.
They wanted like a sacrifice kind of thing going on.
No.
First kids are a place of like a generation of kids.
I'm sorry.
I had a brain aneurysm.
Listen, you know, the death of a character is character development.
Look at us in sync.
End of the show.
What more development do you need at the end of the show?
No, no, no.
It was like just overall she was supposed to die.
I don't know where.
Oh, like in general at some point in the show.
The first pilot of the show basically killed her.
We don't like her.
Get her out of there.
The pilot though, the pilot was such an adult version.
Was it?
You know, you guys can get off here, right?
No, no, no.
We're going the whole way.
Okay.
How do I get off?
Look at the speed runner here.
Okay, ready?
Yeah.
Go.
Oh, what?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
What are we not making?
Oh.
Oh, God, God, God.
Oh, I'm going to my fault or not.
I'm kind of confused.
It was not me.
It was the last one.
I was the last one.
Yeah, it was exactly, yeah, exactly.
You dragged them down.
She's too late.
Yeah, I'm fine.
Are you sure you don't want to do the teleport thing?
Okay, we'd have to leave the restart.
Yeah, we'd have to leave the game so I can change it to easy mode, I think.
No, no, wait, wait, wait.
You know what? Honestly, we're so early, you know.
We're not going to be losing any progress.
We won't. Is it a different map?
I don't think so. No, it's the same map.
OK, well, let's teleport to where you fell from.
You want to do that? Yeah, I'll do it.
But don't you think chat would want us to be in pain?
Yes, they do. OK, chat. Chat, what do you think?
I think chat's on our side.
Don't give them a chance to respond
because we already know what they're going to say.
They're going to say, oh my god, you guys should totally go in easy mode
because once you guys enjoy yourselves.
I believe I believe you and wait.
I believe I'm going to do double Dutch.
What's a double Dutch?
Oh, you don't know what double Dutch is?
No, is it an American thing?
No, it's like, like when you're jump roping.
Yeah, and you got two long ropes and you need three people.
So two people are like, yeah.
You never asked.
Did you ever skip rope, Emmy?
I guess I didn't have the friends for double Dutch as a kid.
Well, I only did it because I was out of my man
in an after school program because I was dumb.
OK, well, they said we're not dumb.
They said we have to suffer for their amusement.
Yeah, my chat also said hard motor bust.
Bust? Can we bust?
What does bust mean? I can bust.
Bust a move. I can't crouch.
So I can't work.
Guys, please.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Why are you just committing suicide all over there?
I thought we were ready to go.
I got eight jumps.
Ready to go?
Ready to go.
OK, I can't read your mind, y'all.
Well, try.
Try harder. I'm trying my hardest.
My telepathy is out of.
We should be. We're literally vibing.
You guys were like, I have to jump off right now.
We were vibing with each other.
See, we were like, oh, it's time to go.
Maybe maybe we need to swap the flats with the the the mommies.
What do you mean by that?
I don't know.
It means in me is is the flight that goes with Shabby's mommy.
And I don't want to live anymore.
She's.
You're trying to replace me.
Yes.
What do you mean by that?
Well, I mean, you should be is a rabbit.
And I am a guinea pig.
So like to a bitch and who's going to feed you?
I could cheat her because I'll share my snacks.
Yeah, we eat the same food.
Yeah, basically.
I don't like carrots.
What do you like?
Lettuce.
I'll feed you some lettuce.
Do you like arugula?
Arugula.
I mean, I'll eat it.
You like zucchini.
My mom just grew some zucchini in her garden.
Oh, my God, I love zucchini.
And she's a little guinea pig.
Do anything else with it.
Actually, you know, my guinea pigs,
the ones I owned, ready?
Um, we fed them like exotic Asian fruits.
Damn.
Impressive, like what?
Do you guys know, like, like leechy?
Oh, yeah, we gave them leechy.
We gave them a rambutan.
Mangosteen.
Oh, damn.
Those are some well fed.
Yeah, they were fast.
They were fat.
Of course, guinea pigs are always
really cute.
Ready?
Quite a ton.
Oh, please.
OK, we did it.
We did it.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
It's OK.
I'm going to make it.
Wait, wait, wait, OK, ready?
Ready?
Yeah, yeah.
Go.
OK, I do not like these cablings.
We're so good at this.
Don't say that right here.
Every time we say that, we.
OK, so we got a.
We got a.
Climb up here.
And I can't climb for some reason.
Oh, it's this again.
Yep.
And then we got to be able to jump on the rocks later.
If you look up, you can see where we are.
Look up.
Oh, I don't want to look up.
Did you see your cheeks?
Look down.
Oh.
Here, the screams of the dams.
Very nice.
Are we in hell right now?
It's kind of like Florida.
Yeah, I was going to say Florida.
You don't like Florida?
No, I've been multiple times.
What is Florida ever to do with?
I went to Florida and they had a lot of little.
I don't like Gators.
They do don't like Gators.
Oh, I like the one of the iguanas.
Oh, it's kind of cool.
But you don't like the dog of the.
You call me.
No, I just don't like alligators.
They are scary.
It tastes really good, though.
What's up?
But it's just the way that you're like walking.
It's so funny to me.
It's the meta.
She's just like tap W to me.
I don't want to be the reason we are walking at like normal.
Everybody else is going like this.
Look, we're cautious.
Sorry if we fall.
It should be small.
Yeah, I saw that.
She jumped up.
I'm trying.
He jumped up forward.
Jump up in front of you.
He forgot how to hit.
Almost killed us.
I was pressing the space bar.
OK.
I don't want it.
OK, OK, OK.
Ready?
Where do we go?
Aim at that stationary rock.
You see that rock with the vines?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go for the vine.
Ready?
Yes.
3, 2, 1, go.
Oh, we're going to make it.
OK.
OK, OK, OK, OK, OK.
And then we're going to time this.
Yeah, and then we got to just like run and book it.
OK?
OK.
Rock over there.
Run button.
Shift.
Shift?
OK, OK.
I'm ready.
You guys ready?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got the next one.
OK.
This one.
Go.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
OK.
Ah.
We did it.
We climbed the ladder.
Come on, look at that.
Wait, are we still in hard mode?
No, we're in normal mode.
No, no, this is hard mode.
I don't think there's a hard or mode.
I think it's either normal or easy.
No, there was a hard mode, I think.
Oh, I wonder what that would be like then.
Hard mode.
Everything's faster.
I don't think there is checkpoints at all on this one.
OK, jump.
OK, so for this one.
You climb the ladder, you got to time it,
because you can see the little thingies.
The what?
Oh.
The little spikes.
Spikes.
OK, wait, let's look at the little spikes.
No, Amy.
OK, now we can go.
OK, OK, OK.
OK.
Pause.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
OK, OK, OK, OK.
Very good.
Who was that?
I don't know.
I think it was all of us.
No, no, no, I think it was like, I don't know.
Maybe it was me.
I don't know.
You can blame me.
OK.
OK, we got it this time.
Alcohol.
Oh, we're going to get hit.
We're going to get hit.
No, we're not.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
The ladder.
It's fine.
OK.
Maybe we're just bad at this timing thing.
I thought it was easier to see them from the side.
Do you want to?
OK.
Oh, true, duh.
So like, look at them from the side.
Oh.
OK.
I'll stack up right here.
Help.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
OK.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, OK.
OK, go a little closer.
You're going to go a little closer.
OK.
OK, wait for it.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
OK, this one we're going to get messed up on a lot.
Like, this one.
No, we didn't.
Shut up.
You're jinxing it.
No, no, we're fine.
I'm just being.
Look, we're geniuses.
We all have two brain cells.
together. They make six. Wait, I was going to say that makes two. So you know where I'm at in this.
I was about to say. We have two brain cells each. That makes six. Two, eight, ten. Wait, two, four,
six, eight. I think we all lost one because of that. No, no, no, no, no, no. I didn't say anything.
Okay, ready? You guys want to get to the edge of glory right over here? Okay, okay. A little
we're going to go. We're going to edge ourselves. We got to time it. Okay.
Okay. Wait, do we do it when it's close? Next one. Yeah, I'm going to jump. So jump.
Don't jump. Oh, you got a backward. Oh, never mind.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Are we stalled? Why are you always pulling everyone up?
I'm lagging a little bit. I'm lagging a little bit.
Okay, you're going to get me. I'm going to get me. I'm stuck. I'm stuck. Okay, I got it. Oh my
God, you're God. You're literally carrying us right now. A gamer is putting into work right now.
So we got to jump, then jump. You got to kind of like, you got to like pull. So look at me.
Well, you guys can see me. It doesn't matter. I don't know why I'm asking you to turn around.
So you got to kind of like jump, but then like press the back button to bring yourself backwards.
You said a lot and I did not know what you said. So W jump. WS. WS. WS. Space WS. Space WS.
Okay. Okay, okay, okay. Okay. You don't want to overshoot it. Yeah, when do we jump? Next one?
Let's do the next one, not this one. I'm so nervous. It's going to jump whenever everybody else
does. Okay. Thank God. We did it. Oh my God. It's like excited little jump. She's like, yeah.
Oh my God. There's a countdown. What? There's a countdown? Yeah, I just read the chat and they
said it's three. R. R? What? What is this countdown for? Oh, it's time to go together. Oh, okay.
Okay. I felt like how we don't do it at the time. We don't need a countdown. We got this. Yeah,
we got scared. Stop it. Watch how you fall. Go. These look like triscuits. They do look like
triscuits. I want triscuits. I don't actually do. Which direction? What's a triscuit this way?
You don't know what a triscuit is? No. It's serial. I don't even know how to explain it. No, it's
like a triscuit. You know miniweeds like frosted miniweeds. It's that.
Wait. What is this? We have to accept it.
Let's stop being stupid. Let's stop being stupid. You fucking asshole. I didn't make it.
Okay. Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go. We have to. No, guys. We got to just,
you got to jump. Jump, jump, jump. Oh, jump. Oh, oh, oh. I got it. I got it. We got it. We got it.
What's that about? Yeah. Maybe I got to put more faith in us then. I'm sorry. It's okay.
You forget. We're gamers. All four of us gamers. We're going to breed. Those brain cells are going
crazy right now. Those six brain cells. Oh, shit.
Wait, where do we go from here? To the side. Oh, okay. There we go. And then we go up.
Inside. Oh, there's our house. There's a ladder right here. This is where we live.
We live now. It's my basement. A basement. Yeah. I'll be, I'll be the stern mother that works.
Jimmy is literally a pit of me of a potato.
Oh, my God.
Okay. So this has lasers that will knock us off. Does anybody want to take a rest in the
hut before we continue? Yeah. How do we crowd? I don't think there is a crowd. I think we should
make out. I would just make out. This is the goon shack. I love you. The goon shack, yeah.
I found out the other day what, what a female gooner is. What's a female gooner? What's a
goonette? Goonette? Yeah, a goonette. It sounds like a band. It does. It sounds like also on the
goonettes. Ready? Okay. Jump when it gets close to you. Yeah. Run. Oh, my God. Okay, we're good.
God, nice job. I don't know where we go from here. Are you clenched? Oh, do we jump to the right?
No, do we jump to up here? Do we reach it? Yeah, I think we can reach it. Yeah, I think we can like
run. Yeah, yeah. Ready? One, two, three, go. Go touch the trampoline. Okay, ready? Okay, ready?
Yeah. Where do we jump to? Right in front of us. Oh, the trampoline. Go. Nice, nice, nice. The trampoline.
Oh, my God. Oh, no.
It's fine. It's fine. I know what's happened. Again, Emmy carrying us. I can't get up.
Emmy, Emmy, actually, you know what I want to do? Can you grab that hook? Can you jump up and grab it?
Okay. Help me, please. Okay, I'm grabbing it.
When do I let go? Don't let go. When do I let go? You'll know when. Just don't let go.
Or I will cry profusely. Well, how am I supposed to know when I'm supposed to know?
Because we're going to be near a platform. Don't worry. We are here. You'll know. You'll know deep in
your heart. Okay. If you hold on for too long, what does it do? Oh, is this it? We're almost there.
Here we are. It's the car. Okay, so whoever gets in the car first will drive. I don't want to drive.
Wait, wait, but before we go, let me explain. Okay, okay. There are obstacles. You may fall off the
map if we fall off the map, but then we got to do this all over. Okay? Okay. Not it. I'm an amazing
driver. Not it. I don't trust you. I don't trust you. You're the biker. Yeah, you're a biker. You
should know what you're doing. Don't go too fast. Don't go too fast. Don't be speeding now.
Oh, no. Wait, speed limit, please. There we go.
We might die.
You know, you guys don't trust me. I can't do this.
No, it's cold.
Where did you get your driver's license?
What do you mean? I'm rocks. Please watch out for the rocks.
You don't trust me. I'm hearing a lot of doubt in your voices right now. A lot of doubt.
Oh, I'm so scared. We're going to get so scared.
I'm so scared. We don't have to go too much. Okay.
Mip has hit every single one of us down. We made it. We made it, didn't we? We did. We did.
Amazing job, Mip, honestly. I knew I had precious cargo. I had three precious packages
in the back. I couldn't crash for you guys. I can't recall if this is a checkpoint or not.
I don't think we get checkpoints. Oh, my God. I was laughing so hard. I was crying.
Even in the normal, they're like checkpoints. Okay, good. Oh, my God. I was crying.
Have you gotten this far before? No. No. Okay. Let me explain. Okay. I see it's twisting.
Oh, is it Cuba? Yes. So you literally just have to run. Don't do it yet.
Wait. I paused. You got to jump almost. What? Yeah. When did my model change?
Oh, what? What do you mean? Why are you a different dude?
I was an old guy, and now I'm not.
Look, you got none. No, you're not. Just ask, what is the problem?
I guess it's the one we got in the car.
Holy shit. You got you. You're not the new character.
Probably when we got in the car. No, no, no. I was still the old guy when we were in the car.
My driving changed you. You're driving made me like age. Yeah. Yeah. I was just a good driver.
And it made me probably age even more absorbed for elderlyness. Okay. Okay. Okay. So literally,
you just have to stand on top of it after you climb to the top and just jump with the spins.
Huh? Okay. Yeah. I did not understand anything. Do I just jump in general when it spins?
Yeah. You just jump in general. Oh, you just stand still and jump? Yeah. So you can jump onto it now.
Good luck. Okay. We did it. We did it. We did it. We did it. It's going to rotate. I can't even get up, bro.
Okay. Guys, please. Don't worry. We got this. Okay. Okay. Okay. We're fine.
Okay. I did it. I did it. I did it. We did it. We did it. It's going to rotate again.
Okay, and then jump off
Okay, this one we just have to like climb it's not really big. Okay. Okay. How do we come this?
Oh, we jump when it gets closer. Yeah
I'm trying to pull
No, I can't do anything that's why I was like, I don't know what's happening. Oh shit, sorry
No
Oh
Why can't I pull you forward you're too weak. What I get maybe I am because all these characters
Yeah, you can jump whenever oh
It's called being good at this game come on now
All right, let's uh, let's jump over here. We want to be the next
Yeah, well actually according to my calculation
What was that? Oh like
No, I just got up here. You guys didn't have to follow me
We're just standing here looking pretty while you use your big brain
I'm the mad. I'm the mad and we listen to you. This is just typical platforming
Great, okay
Maybe we can do three two one countdown. No, okay
I'm falling off the blocks of tofu
I'm trying to make sure that we don't die. I'm sure I'm trying to make sure that we don't die
Maybe I'm stuck
I'm falling off the wall
I was trying to have to fall
I'm being pulled down
Oh
Please don't fall. Don't leave me here alone. Don't leave me here
Help me
Use your giant skinny pig ass and come up here. Please
I'm getting pulled down tuna. She be come on. I'm trying. I'm trying
Okay, I genuinely cannot pull myself off right here
Oh
You have to swing
Oh, okay
I'm so exhausted
My arms are giving out
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay. Okay, just swing a little bit
I'm not even kidding. I'm trying to pull myself up and I legitimately
But you have to you cannot be serious girl
Oh, wow, that was our first call guys. Can you believe how far we got?
Oh my god, I laughed so hard. I actually started crying. Did you pee a little too?
Maybe
Want me to bottle up for you?
Yeah
Okay, don't worry guys. Okay
Best driver in a back at it again
You gotta play mario par with you guys. I swear
Oh my god, I laughed so hard my chest
My chest hurts too
Oh, I have not laughed this hard in just so long
I can't
I can't do this on purpose
What do you mean? I'm an amazing driver
Oh my god, I laughed so hard
Oh my god, I even got this this one's easy
I want to see if I can change my character
I missed
Okay, this one's hard to mess up this one's hard to mess up. Don't say that
I'm saying you all just fucking fall off
This is so hard to mess up. Okay. Come on. Just this one's easy too. There you go. Yeah. Yeah, we're we're parkour guys
Yeah, best climbers
Oh, I'm my eyes are actually blurred from laughing so hard
I can't
I can't jump
I'm in the wall
You can jump till sweat dropped down my balls
Oh
The next one
Hi
I changed characters and I was wondering if I could go back to being an old guy
Oh, wait, is you changed characters because you clicked on wait, what?
I stood in there is when I noticed I changed characters. I thought maybe if I did it again, I could be the old guy
Maybe I don't know why I changed you. Maybe you gotta get to another checkpoint
Or that why can't we all be an old guy? Well, I don't want to be old and ugly. I don't want to be old
You're saying I'm old and ugly
Look at that model. He definitely gets bitches. Look at him. I'm pulling you all towards me. Emmy. You're lucky
You're on the other end where I pull you and dangle you off
All right, let's not okay count down. We got this
Yeah, do the countdown. Okay. Three two three go
Oh, okay, or we can press I thought we were gonna press stop
Stop press the R button. Thank you. Okay
Okay, okay
Okay, I like how you're jumping
Just go on without me just go
All right. I'm good. Listen. I can't see very well right now. Okay
Get a napkin
There you go. Get a napkin. No, no, I'm bottling it. I'm bottling it
You're bottling your tears the gamer girl tears. Oh, yeah, all right now. We can just run now. We're good. No, we're fine
Well, just be mindful be mindful where people are
I'm biting my face
Oh, we got it. We got it. We got it. We got to win. I can't see
Do it do it do it
Piss piss piss
Okay
Yes
Very demure
Very demure. Very cutesy. Okay, very demure. Very cutesy piss
Okay, I guess we're just going a little bit easier. Oh my God. Maybe not. Maybe. Maybe it's not so easy.
Oh no. Oh no. Not the falto. Not the falto at the end. The falto, please.
I got you. Okay, I can't help. Viv's gonna have to do it. Oh my God. This is hard.
You're gonna have to do it. You're gonna have to pull Viv. You're gonna have to pull Viv.
Oh my God, you're gonna have to pull me. No, you're fine. It's fine. It's fine.
Okay, I got Amy. Okay, we got all the useful people. Can we turn around? Let me turn around.
Oh, I did that. I saved you. Yeah, after you endangered us half the game. There we go.
I did not do that. I'm at the end. It's not my fault. All right, there's a trampoline. Be mindful of it.
Okay, I will be mindful. Ready? Are you serious? Are you serious?
Are you serious?
Wait, wait, wait, wait. I went through the island.
Okay. That's crazy. Who could have done that? That's wild.
That's crazy. I said, watch out.
I said, oops. I said, oops.
All right, let's jump onto this rock, ladies. Okay. Okay.
This is the way any one of you. Okay. It doesn't matter which direction you go in.
Oh, there are dead ends. You're not letting me. But you'll see the dead ends because we gotta wait for Stoppy.
Okay. You're fucking out. What just happened? Okay, all right.
Oh, no, this is the nearest safe location. I tried to teleport to the nearest safe location.
So should we go into easy mode? Wait, there's no safe point? No, I don't see one in any of the settings.
Can we go to easy mode now, please? Chad, can we have permission for easy mode?
I don't think we should. Everyone's on your side. Does it have to be the person who's running the thing to do it?
I think I have to just restart it. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Chad, can we do it?
Oh, my God. That was so funny.
My computer is struggling right now. Everybody is in like two frames per second.
We're in PowerPoint mode.
That was so funny. Oh, my God.
Okay, it's going to be the same. Oh, wait. If I type in the password, oh, no, they can't see. Okay, that's good.
Just get rid of it real quick. Get rid of what? Like hide the game. Just kill me. Just do it.
Okay, same password. Same password. And it's going to be beginner mode. Yeah, okay.
Finally, we're free. Should I do closed chain? No. I don't know what that means.
So it's we're all connected to each other rather than being like a line. Yeah, we're all connected to each other.
Wait, no. Don't do that. Okay, okay. Wait, wouldn't that be easier? No. No.
Wait, did you open the thing? I'm creating the session right now. Oh, we're just inpatient. Sorry.
There you go. You can join. Should we all be old men? Yes.
There's Steve from Minecraft. I'd rather be a hag, honestly. Is there even a hag? No, I'm not a hag.
Wait, that's wrong password. Oh, shit. What did you do? I swear I put the same password. Let me just check what I wrote in there.
Did you spell it wrong? I wouldn't do that. I'm going to join last so I can be at the end. Post a game.
Yeah, you need your goats at the end, huh? You know what? The two mommies need to be the front and the caboose that's in there.
Well, that would mean that me. Sandwich us. I'm a baby. Mommy, me, me, momma, momma.
I require mommy, milky, please. I'm a baby.
Okay, I made it again.
Welcome to the bathroom real quick. Don't start the game without me.
Don't start the game without you? Don't start the game without me.
Just drag her like a corpse. Yeah.
I can't get in. Is this wrong password? You got to refresh it. You got to refresh it. Is this wrong password again?
Hold on, let me refresh. Can you guys not spell the password? No. Wait. Okay, I'm in. Okay, okay, now I'll be right back.
I think you just had to like refresh it. Yeah, I had to refresh the entire thingy.
Should we all just be buff men? No, I want to be an old guy.
He looks like his name is like Walter. If I'm a buff guy, will I be able to carry people better?
No, I don't think so. But I need to go to the bathroom too. I'll go real quick.
Let's see. You know when you load it in, I thought it said skibbity.
Wow, I can't believe you've said that. I'm so sorry. The brain rot.
No, it's okay. I'll say what the shibbity a lot. So it's fine.
What the shibbity?
We can't even start the game without her. So I don't know why she thinks we can.
I would have dragged both of them, honestly, and blamed them if we fell.
Look at their little bodies.
Aw, they look so cute. Oh, I just realized. So far off those ears flick.
That's really adorable. That is really cute.
And then Amy has a snot bubble when she sleeps, but I do too.
You do? Yeah, I did that. I don't know if it'll work because I might have taken it off.
No. Sometimes if I just like go off to the side too far, I just like fall asleep.
It's like how Emmys is right now. Man, it takes a long piss.
You know, some people wash their hands. Is that new to you?
You want to smell them? It's fire cracker. I bet you just rinse your hands with the water.
You don't even put soap on it. No, I use bath and body work soap. You know, I'm a sink queen.
She washes, she dips her hands in the toilet after.
You know when I was crazy? Me?
No. You know, sometimes if you have the toilet and then if it's too forceful, it's too powerful, the water will splash up.
Are you talking about when we sit on the toilet and we piss hard, the water will splash back on us?
No, no, no. When you're flushing it and sometimes it gets on the seat.
No. So it happens in like public restroom sometimes.
If I see that, I immediately just go to a different bathroom.
Same. I hold it. Like I can't deal with that.
Just piss. Just squat over the seat. Don't sit down. Just squat.
I don't like squatting. I'll just bare ass it.
I can't squat. I mean, I can, but like I don't like it.
So you'll bare ass stick your ass on a nasty toilet seat if you had to?
No, I just hold it.
I'll do it.
I've had to. The only time I squized in a porta potty because hell no.
I don't have it in me to use a porta potty. I think I'd rather pee.
I've never used a porta potty. When I went to a run fair, I had to use a porta potty because I was really going to piss myself.
You could have bottled it.
I don't. I did not have a bottle nearby.
I've had to pee in a cup for a doctor's appointment before and I hated it.
Yeah. Peeing in a cup is fun.
It makes me nervous because then I can't pee.
And then they're like, are you done yet? And I'm like, no, I can't.
I just go into Zen mode and I breathe deeply.
And then I just go as you.
And then as I blow out, I piss.
Are you a strong pisser or like a gentle pisser?
I'm a gentle pisser.
What's the difference?
I just let it dribble.
You know, I don't have to force it.
What?
I like forcing it. I think it feels nice.
I have a great pelvic floor strength, though. Don't get it twisted.
No, no, I believe you. I believe it's great.
You think it feels nice to force it out?
Yeah.
It does. 100%. I love it.
If you just like really piss really hard.
You're like, ugh.
Just like generally.
What is he? How hard I can piss?
You like that, baby?
Check it in there.
Pissing all by yourself handsome.
Oh my.
Oh my God.
Yes. You want to hold my hand while I piss?
I think Viv has met her match.
Hello.
I see a lot of myself in Viv.
You know.
Because we're old.
No.
Viv is a hag.
Hags are in demand.
Maybe not.
Maybe other hags. I don't know about you.
But it's all running in sync.
I'm pretty proud of us.
Why did you stop?
I dropped something, but I don't know where it is.
Is it this big rock?
Is it my boobs?
Is it your boobs?
You drop your pocket.
You will see me in Japan.
My boobs, I'm pretty sure are bigger than yours.
And they're softer than yours.
My boobs are great.
What the fuck?
I don't know about that.
You felt each other's boobs?
How do you know they're so good?
We're gonna.
In October, we're gonna feel each other's boobs.
Oh, you guys do an off collab in Japan?
Yeah.
No.
I wanna see her.
You don't wanna see her?
She's mean to me.
You're kind of mean back though.
Yeah.
You're very soon.
Yeah, here I am.
She's made.
But Pookie, you're my soulmate.
No, we're twin flames because we're out.
Nice callback.
Love that.
The underworld.
Already off to a great start ladies.
I thought we were taking the shortcut.
I was like, because of her.
We are.
Oh, that shortcut.
We're just not ready for it.
Okay.
Oh, I just assume.
At least now when we fall off, we'll start back up here.
Yeah.
I think we lost a brain cell because of the piss talk.
Probably.
What were you guys talking about?
We were talking about how long you were pissing and then we were just talking about pissing
in general.
We were talking about porta-potties and how we hate porta-potties.
Yeah.
And how we over squat.
Do you squat or do you bare ass a toilet?
Or do you put a little liner down in me?
It really depends.
I never really squat though.
If it's too dirty, I just don't go.
Yeah.
Exactly.
But what if you have to?
Then I'll piss on the fucking floor.
Piss on the floor.
I'm kidding.
Piss in the middle of a Walmart.
Did you guys see that TikTok of the girl that shot herself in Walmart?
I stored there.
What?
She recorded a TikTok of her crying and she's like, guys, I just shot myself in Walmart.
Of course it happens at a Walmart.
It's always the Walmart.
There's somebody who was like, I saw someone shit.
Someone else made another TikTok.
Guys, I just saw someone shit in the Walmart.
I love it when there's like TikToks of multiple angles and stories of the same thing.
Oh my God.
I think the power of us talking about piss and shit is making us play really good.
I know.
We're not even thinking.
We're just going.
We're just so focused.
We just turned our brain off.
Yeah.
More piss and shit talk.
Oh, never mind.
I think it's or because we're all old men.
Maybe.
Maybe it's the power of it.
I don't know.
I just fell off.
I guess we really fell off.
He didn't handle it.
What did weight girls actually shit?
Something.
Something like that.
We do something like the male equivalent, but it's not quite fitting.
You know, like how owls like puke out the bones?
That's kind of.
Yeah.
We grind stuff in our gizzard and then we throw it up.
That's basically what girls do.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
Guys, we're good.
We got this.
Even if we fall off, we have the checkpoint stuff.
So it's not a really big deal.
We got it.
Keep going to the side.
Yeah.
Go for it.
Everyone.
Oh, I keep forgetting you can sprint.
Sprint.
Come on.
Use your old man legs.
Follow me.
Pull me to victory.
I'm getting held back by you.
I'm seeing so proud of this bangle.
I'm trying to go forward.
I'm trying to go forward and she's just like not moving.
Go our leader, our fearless leader.
Me?
Yeah.
Yes.
You're the fearless leader.
Cute girls go first.
Cute girls first.
Me and Viv go last because we're hacks.
Yeah, because we're old.
I'm 56 years old.
My birthday's coming up.
I'm turning 57.
Oh, damn.
Nah, forever 56.
You wear diapers?
Uh, yeah.
You sell those diapers?
Do I sell them?
You're talking, yeah.
You only have two dollars.
You can't afford them.
Well, look, I can pay in other ways.
Your body?
Eyebrow.
Yeah.
Wait a second.
Sorry.
I got distracted by our diaper talk.
Yeah.
I was wondering too.
I mean, I can sell you like a liver.
Like, do you sell them on eBay?
I can do that.
A liver.
I like to make the likes of art with the remnants of what's inside.
I feel like Etsy.
Yeah.
Etsy.
Is this against your terms of service?
No.
As long as you don't stay.
That's why we keep it on the DL.
It's a secret operation.
Secret biohazard.
That's what the store is called.
How did you know?
Oh, yeah.
Secret biohazard.
What's up?
Okay.
You know, the old men.
We're quadruplets.
I know.
They call us the retirement home.
Okay.
Soppy, you're a son of a bitch.
Sorry, mom.
Wait.
Oops.
We were ready.
Apparently we were ready.
Sorry.
We did the time.
We weren't going to make it though.
I did it the time.
Pick it up.
Help me.
Okay.
No, no, no.
I'm ready.
Yeah.
Go.
Okay.
We were in sync on that one.
Nice.
That was pretty good.
Okay.
This one, this one, this one.
I don't think we can count down this one.
I think we got to just say this one.
This one, this one, this one.
This one.
Go.
Send it.
Remember, you can sprint.
Yes.
Okay.
You've played.
I'm so proud of us.
Oh, there's only three.
Oh, no, we're doing.
Wait, why did I just fall off?
Can I sprint up the ladder?
Timer?
No.
That's just how much time has taken us so far.
Only six minutes.
Yeah.
It's not bad.
Those people probably speed run this.
Yeah.
Probably.
I didn't even notice.
Oh, yeah.
We're speed running this.
Wait, let me hide.
Wait, can you guys wait?
This game is actually really long.
Are you ready?
Can you guys pause real quick?
Yeah.
Let me turn and move my stuff so they can see how.
Why are you?
Look how it was posted.
Are you like that?
The spread eagle.
Yeah, I'm giving you a show.
Oh, the spread.
Do you guys ever watch Chicago?
No.
Chicago.
Wait, is it ready?
No.
It's the one where it's like snow block tango.
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
I know that.
And then they're like her like sister and her husband were doing the spread eagle.
Ready?
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I know you should describe it more in detail though.
I just always thought spread eagles and your legs are just like in the air like spread.
I don't know what it is.
No, no, no, it is what it is.
But that was like also the hell I'm stuck behind the ladder.
Don't worry.
We'll pull you up.
I keep getting stuck on stuff.
Okay, we'll pull you up.
Thank you.
It was so nice.
I'm not having to be at the end.
I will jump off right now.
Do not test me.
Well, if you do it, do it.
Do it.
Jump.
Wow.
I'm so edgy.
I'm acting.
Do it.
It's like your toddler proof stuffy.
Okay.
Amazing timing.
No.
Okay.
Oh, look at that.
I'm like, oh, we all just waited.
We're not that dumb.
We still got six brain cells.
Wait.
We lost you because we missed the number the first time and then we talked about this.
Oh, my game is lagging.
Oh, pause.
Let me fix your game.
Pause, pause, pause.
Pause.
I'm good.
You're on a diet.
Stop.
Okay.
I'm feeling chaotic.
Go, go, go, go.
This actually works out.
Oh, my God.
That's fine.
I was dangled off the side.
Okay.
It works out.
Because if you like kind of like do the balancing and like two people are on one side and two
people are on the other, you can kind of get under some of the obstacles.
Oh, I didn't mean to fall off.
Sorry.
All right.
Ready?
Go.
I guess.
Around you.
Where am I going?
I can't tell which one's me anymore.
Okay.
Let's go.
Hag Squad is this way.
That's right.
We go up here.
Hag Squad.
Wait.
What's the what's the what's the Hag what's the male version of Hag?
Just old man.
Oh, Jesus.
Okay.
Hag Squad.
Let's go.
Teresa Squad.
Oh.
Oh, Jesus.
Oh, Jesus, oh, Jesus.
There you go.
I wasn't looking at us.
It's already.
Don't go yet.
No.
I'm so sorry.
No, I'm sorry.
You are a run ahead and then jump.
It's fine.
Just press the button, press the button.
Is that so much better?
Do it again to see if we change again
Oh, jeez, I'm back. Oh, go don't worry
Got you I got you. I want some ice cream. I do too. I'm just like craving. Maybe you should get some sherbert
Cuz I'm alert. Well, I'm not allergic, but I'm
But there's there's milk and sherbert your lack
Sorbet
I did it I touched it I did it I touched it again
Okay, okay, okay, we got this
Okay, yeah, just go go go go go. There you go. You'll speed run speed run
Go
Wait, wait, wait. Oh good job. Grab the hook. Grab the hook
Yay
I was about to climb off just just climbed up just to get taken off
Here we go. We're heading to the car
The car all the car
But then there's the car that's driver bib has it
I don't I have a feeling she's gonna lose this time
Wait, wait, wait, do you want to I kind of want to watch the emi or sefalto try to drive now that we have the checkpoint
Yeah, you're right. You're right
I don't have a driver's license. I don't know if I mean, this is your training right here. Yeah, this is this is the this is the
The test
Okay, I'll drive go get in the back ladies
Get in there. We're going
How do I turn?
You did it. You got it. You got it. You got this. Oh, I have to be moving forward to turn. Yeah, yep
Okay, okay. Yeah, you're making fun of me in my driving
See how it is harder than it looks
Oh boy
Okay, but I won't be running into every single one of these
excuse
We'll see you say one
I won't I won't not every single one you got to go faster to avoid them. They actually don't really knock you off
They kind of just bop you
Oh nice
Stay in your seat
Maybe it's because we're on easy mode
Even on easy mode you can fall off
Okay
We made it
Thanks, OG Sonny
Thanks, OG Sonny, did that
You're very welcome
I think you got your garbage license on that one
And jump and jump again
And we jump again
And then we're dead
I'm not gonna link it
Oh, it's okay. We can drive back. Oh, okay. Sopralto, wait
Oh, no, we don't need you
No, I won't
It's really funny if Sopralto freaking
I'll jump right now. Let's go do it. Let's do it. Let's do it. Come on. Wait. Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. Let's do it
Yeah, you can do it
This is gonna be all on come on sloppy hands
Okay
Oh, you're going fast. Okay. Oh, she's doing okay
Oh, he's Mario Kart
Mario Kart? Kill him
Don't actually kill him
Okay, nice. Okay, keep going. Oh, she's driving backwards. That's a deal
I'm trying to figure out how to reverse
Yeah
There you go. Point turn
That was almost as good as the board
Oh, don't make me laugh. I'm gonna make Mrs. Sopralto
Yeah, you got this. Probably we're gonna mess it up anyways, but yeah
No, we're gonna have pain
You know, maybe guinea pigs shouldn't drive
No, you're doing it. If you just go over it, baby
She's doing it. She's doing it
You're not going backwards. Are you threatening to kill us? What's happening?
Yes
I don't think I want to be a passenger princess anymore
Oh my god
It's okay. We're back here. We're still on the road. We're starting backwards. How do I turn around?
Oh
No, you can't do this. I believe in you. Oh my god. Just drive backwards. Just drive backwards. Yeah, just drive backwards. Yeah
Just stay backwards. I can't see
Turn your camera
Wait, I got it. Wait, I could use the ramp to help me. Oh my god
Oh my god
Soppy
What's he doing? What's he doing here, sweetie?
Oh, he got it. He got it. Okay
Mario Karting
Oh
I can't believe this is happening again
Okay, if you got this don't run into these things
Baby pull this back
All right, now we know where that was gonna go. Yeah
Oh
I wish they had like little dances like a little fortnight like I could eat about
Justice here. Exactly. This is me dancing. Oh my god. I'm laughing again. So hard that I like a little bit of a
Chocolate
This is not a good dance
Maybe if we were talking about piss, I would have done better. You ever saw that guy?
Okay, okay. What's your favorite flavor of piss?
apple red
Oh
I could drive again
Did she be good in the front? Oh, who's in the front right now?
Okay, okay. Thank goodness. Thank goodness
Wait, why am I going backwards? I'm in the front. You are? What? Yeah. Oh, I thought I was driving
Wait, who's driving me? Are you really? Are you serious? I was like, wait, that can't be me
Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah
Yeah, that's Soppy
I've never gotten pulled over and I have a really good license just not in hell
You know, I don't know if that's true. I think you're lying to us
I think you're like driver's license is fake. Did you die in a car crash? Is that how you got to hell?
Because she crashed a car. She had like 50 pedestrians
She crashed during her training
Go
All right my turn
Okay
I like how entertained we are by this car
We just want to see everyone's driving
I wish I could jump and do flips. Can I go faster? No, this is the max you can go
Okay, okay, you're doing really good. I'm not sucking it off
It's it's because you're just a bad driver, babe
Yippie
Sorry pretty sold
You're just a bad driver proceeds to get out of the car
Well, getting off the car is a lot better than driving off the
You saw me so bad
There's no way I was doing pretty good
I was going no stop. Okay made it to the end somebody's a decent driver here, you know, not you
Not definitely not you
Oh, wait, are the chains real? I thought the chains were like
They do get stuck on some things but some things they don't get stuck on these like the thin things you can get past
Okay, okay
Please stay on the cube this time. I'm ready to throw myself off the cube. Okay, he's gonna spin. Okay
I have already thrown myself off the cube
Please remain on the cube
I'm on the cube
I'm on the cube. I am no longer on the cube stay on the cube. I'm on the cube
Okay, it just sounds fun only the main character. So now I'll respond like right here. So it's fine
The entire time you're not a main character
I was on the cube though. You're like a side character
You're the one that dies on episode three
Oh my god, and you motivate
You motivate everybody else for the rest of the show. I'm sorry
She's the mable sacrifice
I can't
You're pulling me
I cannot see
Hey, look at her. I can't jump up. My head is too big. Okay. There we go. I should be the one saying that come on
Okay, okay, okay. Okay. Why can't I jump?
See it's hard. We have to like go over here and
Yeah, go on the platform
Yeah
We're going without it without me. Yeah
Oh
I
Can't be
Okay, you got me
Now I'm pulling up Poppy. Okay
Good, good. We did it. Hello. We have the giggles too much. It's getting harder. I can't see
Okay
Uh-oh. Hello. I'm an eardrum
That's okay. Thank you. There we go. Okay
Oh, I can see my insides. I did not like that. You can see your insides
I like it like clipped so that I could see my inside of my model. It was kind of
Oh, why are we counting down? I didn't mean to hit that. Oh, okay. I can see inside my pants
I saw inside my pain looks like uh looks like so if you back up against this and like push your mouse forward
Oh, it looks like guts and stuff is through the chain. Yeah
Okay
Go
Because I am exhausted
Okay, okay, okay, okay, and me the true gamer. I'm I'm the sweating never lies
Okay, wow, we're doing so great. I'm so proud of us
Sorry I was on autopilot again
Okay, wow, look at that. We did amazing
Wait, are we grunting are we?
What I didn't know it I wasn't paying for grunts when they jump. Oh oopsie. I hear like, huh
Oh my god, I can make those noises with you
I don't want to make those noises
I don't think I'll ever live these noises down if I make them
Why not that bad? I mean, they'll be in private me and you and maybe a few other people
I'm literally gonna cry, please
Okay, she doesn't want to be roomed with me in japan
Yes, because you're gonna put me in the top chair
Oh
It's better than a cube let's sync up. Let's lock in everyone
Period ready?
Where's we're so
Oh
No, we don't need to see anyone's driving again
What are you trying to say are driving wasn't majestic
Oh, the only driving that was majestic was mine. Oh, wow. Oh, wow. I see how it is. I'm just chopped a liver
No, I think you're already sold your liver than me. Oh, yeah, you're right for 50 bucks
Okay
Okay, okay, no autopilot. We just we go okay. Okay as a unit. Okay. Okay. I'm locked in. I'm locked into I'm clenched
I'm tightened
Okay, do it my kiggles right now. I jump
Okay, three two one go
Oh, we're doing really good. Wow
Don't say that you
Fuck
I'll fall off the edge
We're doing so good right now
Just jump to the box. It'll be easier to pull us up. Okay
Okay, I'm in the screen swinging
Nice, okay, okay
All right, now we can just kind of only two of us are hags
well
No, there's only there's only one ojisan here
Are you calling me elderly?
Yes
Maybe because I have boobs doesn't mean I'm elderly. I also have bowing the longies. No, she doesn't she's smaller than me. I roll
You can't say that on the internet. You're embarrassing me
She's just a lie. She's a sham
Where do we go? Are your boobs okay?
She's lying about your boobs. I have fucking giant titties, bro.
She's not lying at all. She's not a scam like you are, bitch. I'm scamming. I'm a liar
It's okay. I still love you. You're not bad titties
Oh my god, we're going. I was you were ready for this
I was you were ready for this
Oh, what's this button?
Oh, what's this do? Oh, it's time. It's time. It's time by the way. So let's let's just wait a moment. Okay. Okay.
Is this the highest we've ever been? Yes, it is. Mm-hmm. And we're only gonna go higher
Do you think we can finish the game?
No, no
But this with our brains is so much bigger. There's a whole other level before the after this one. Okay. Go go go go go go go
Oh
Yeah, jump
Just try not to vault just try to jump. It's hard. I actually know it. Yeah, I give up. I can't even follow me one fucking advice
Guys you're holding me back here. I'm trying not to
So what'd you say? Buddy hop, buddy hop, buddy hop. Yeah, just buddy hop it
Not even close, baby
I'm not even close. Not even close. Ready? Yes, ready go. Oh, oh wait, wait
Forward to the countdown ready
Go
Okay
Go go get to the another elevator another elevator. Oh
Cute
Oh
Oh, we have a nice ass
Okay, thank you elevator very safely. I think just walk on it. I didn't know you could like fall off of it
We did it gang
Let's fit in the chains now. There we go. It's so funny
Oh
Welcome to the wisdom whispering. Oh, wow. I got an achievement. We too reach the mysterious cave
You guys want to explore feel free. There's nothing but go ahead. No, I'm good
Don't worry. No, the elevator is very safe. Oh water
Well, uh, okay, so be careful because there might be a spot where you can fall through are we naked?
No, no
It looks like we're naked
Wait. Oh, you can dive
Oh, do we do we drown?
No, no, I think we're already dead. So we can't double dive
True, true, true. Oh wait. No, I don't think we're at that water spot yet
Where you have to like swim around all around maze
I'm running
Yeah, they should do that. They should add like a monster that chases you so it's like scarier and hardly hard mode. Yeah
Very safe
Super funny what you guys look like when you look up
Oh, wait, our heads actually turn. Oh, yeah
Okay, so this is a puzzle
Did you say a puzzle? Why are you serious?
It's a puzzle. Okay, guys. We have to jump and we have to hit the buttons
Six brain cells. We got this
16 cells. We have to hit them all. Yes
In order to open the door
Where's the next one?
Oh
I can't remember if they're timed or not. Where's the last button? It's over here
Where I am I'm in I'm in such rock. Help me
Oh, I can't get up. Where's the last button? It's right behind you. I'm here. What?
I'm here. Oh
Sorry, miss. Oh
We did it. Nice. We did it
That puzzle was nothing. Yeah easy easy
Okay, now we gotta make that that sprint and jump sprint jump grab
Hey you saved me, okay
Um, maybe not yet. Huh?
From the side
Go
I'm going. Oh no
Okay, okay. We're good. We're good. We're good. We're good. We're good. We're good
We'll make it
Okay, wait, wait here
Go down. Go down. Go down. Go down. Go down. Go down
Oh, goodbye
Oh
Wait no
Oh, not the oh, hey look we're back to the car
Absolutely not.
It means hell.
It's me driving that car again.
Uh-oh.
I was ready for this.
What's happening to you?
OK, there we go.
It's OK.
We'll just drag you across.
Wait, wait, wait.
No, just drag me.
Just drag me.
It's OK.
I'm stuck.
I'm a fairy.
She was a fairy.
Whee.
Hi, Sophie.
Ah!
No!
Oh!
Back to the car.
You win this car.
You were obsessed with this car.
You just want to drive again.
No.
I think I just like...
She's not allowed to drive a little on the inside.
Oh my god.
You know, I have a very nice car.
That you don't use.
It's a mom van.
You're calling me to give the hag?
Probably has zero miles on it, too.
This is like $25,000.
Miles?
That's pretty good.
I actually don't know what that...
Fuck.
Oh.
It's how many...
It's just how much you've used your car.
But also, my parents gave it to me,
so I could go to college.
To get more knowledge?
Go to college.
Yes.
And then I chose to become a streamer,
so you see where I'm happening.
Oh, that's okay.
Oh, gosh.
This is where me, Azura, Apollo, and Freya got stuck on
really hard core last time,
and we were raging by the end of the week.
Right here, right here, yeah.
He's got to be mindful of the lasers.
Demure, very demure, very mindful.
Okay, be ready to jump.
I'm always mindful.
Okay.
And then where?
Oh, and then right here, too.
Turn to the side, and then go over there.
We're so good at this.
Yeah.
Wait, let us finish this first.
I mean, look at us go.
Where do we go next?
That one?
Oh, okay.
Our massive brain.
We're actually doing a lot better
when I played this last, holy crap.
It's the piss buff.
It's the piss buff, yeah.
The pee pee and the poo poo buff.
Oh, sorry, I jumped too hard.
Sorry, I jumped too soon.
Oh, my God, I'm spazzing out.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, this game's breaking me.
Almost there, almost there.
Okay, we got it, we got it.
We're almost backed up so far.
I fell off.
Okay.
We did it.
You guys couldn't do that?
Yeah, we couldn't.
For some reason.
They didn't have the joint chemistry that we do.
Our brain cells are weak.
I think it was this one, actually, though.
When you fall, you have to start back.
It's okay, we got the button.
We got the button.
You have to start back at them.
That's okay, we're good, we're good.
We're good, we're good.
I believe in level, technically.
I believe in the highest point.
How long have we been doing this?
1.47.
1.45?
Wow, okay.
Oh, sorry, I rounded it.
I'm sorry, I rounded it.
1.45?
1.47 is close enough.
You rounded it.
I don't like that.
Ready, jump.
I missed.
Oh, we were about to fall perfectly in that hole over there.
I fell perfectly in your hole last night.
I fell perfectly in your mom's hole last night.
I wasn't going to say that.
I wasn't going to say that, but I didn't want to be your mom into this.
And now I see that we're allowed to.
Of course we are.
Mom's fair game.
That's what she told me last night.
Me and Amy started the same two brain cells, apparently.
Ready?
Yes.
Okay, don't miss.
Jump.
I didn't even get to jump.
I like someone fell into it.
Who was it?
I jumped on top of it, I'm sorry.
It's okay, I can't be mad at you.
If it was Sobby, I would have been pissed.
I'm going to jump off the map right now.
Don't test me.
Do it.
I'll pee in your fucking suit.
Don't test me.
I know where you live.
You see what I have to do?
Is that mean or me defending myself?
It's kind of hot.
You guys should kiss.
We are.
We're going to hold toes.
Our toes are going to interlock toes.
Interlock toes.
I don't know.
Crazy thing.
I actually don't like people touching my feet.
Really?
Same.
You never had your toes sucked?
Oh my God.
You haven't had me touch your feet, okay?
You don't know what it's like.
One time I went to get a massage and I told the lady not to touch my feet.
Because I felt weird about it.
I just don't like people touching my feet.
I don't know.
I've just been a thing.
Do you get ticklish?
No, no.
I just don't like.
Go, go, go, go.
The only time I'll have people touch my feet is my pedicurist.
And I'll giggle every time and she makes fun of me.
Oh, so you're ticklish?
I'm extremely ticklish on my feet.
Well, you just gave us ammo.
What are you going to do with that ammo?
Tickle the feet.
Come on, Chibi.
You got this.
I'm trying so hard.
Chibi.
You got it.
I'm trying.
I'm trying to pull up.
Chibi.
You saw me pulling it up.
You saw me.
You almost got it.
I stopped his fault.
It was stopped his fault.
I literally, okay, you know what?
I'm not going to fall next time.
It's all your fault.
I literally can't move.
I'm sorry.
I didn't know where you were going.
I was turning on the light and starting my house.
Chibi, you're in the air.
I'm trying to pull.
Oh, my God.
I can't pull both.
Oh, man, it worked out.
Oh, shit.
What was that?
It's the dangle tech.
If we're dangling, we can't get pushed off.
Don't worry about it.
Just keep going.
Okay.
Well, at least you're going.
But there's spikes.
That's okay.
I'll be fine.
Aren't they going to spike us?
Wait.
If we jump.
We're back at the beginning.
I cannot jump.
Flicker.
Oh, back to the car.
Oh, my God.
Back to the car.
I'm going to put a bomb in your car.
Okay.
The next person who falls gets their toes sucked.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Ready?
Yes.
The next person who falls, what?
They get their toes sucked.
They did.
Not by Mimi.
My reward.
My reward?
Was I supposed to be a reward?
I know, like, ticklishness is a fetish.
You don't like ticklishness as a fetish?
Wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, like, I know some people get off from being, like, tickled.
What?
Yeah.
It's a thing.
For sure.
I didn't even know that.
I mean, everything's a fetish to really think about it.
I don't think the point of sexual psychology
is to teach you about every single kink that exists.
No, no, no.
I did learn that there's a difference between a kink
and a fetish.
Oh, wait.
What's the difference?
Oh.
A kink is something that amplifies the do, you know?
OK.
And then a fetish is something like you genuinely need to get off.
Oh.
So Warwick for me.
Yes.
It's a fetish.
OK.
Wait, what's Warwick?
A league.
Don't get into it.
Have you ever heard of the best game ever, League of Legends?
Oh, god.
I'm going to kill myself right now.
I'm going to throw myself off.
With over 150 characters you could play?
No.
It's OK.
You don't have to tell me about it.
Oh.
OK.
No!
Stop it.
That's on me.
No, no.
That's Shibi.
That's not me this time.
Or is that me this time?
I'll have you know, and you'll have me this time.
Ah!
Jump!
I feel like
Hey, we actually made it.
We got our two dogs at the park, and we're just holding them back.
I have to toot.
Do it.
Turn around.
Put it in, like, right in my head.
No, I'm not good.
You guys never cared about that lady who, like, went to the hospital?
You guess she farmed.
She captured her jars, her farts and jars.
And then she like ate like a shit ton of beans and stuff too wait
Why did she go to the hospital for capturing too much? He farted too much that her like her her like
Her tummy herdy really baddie. Yeah, that's me for real for real
But yeah, basically she was like she was selling her farts. Oh
Like over a hundred times a day, I think oh
I heard about this her he was a streamer too. Yeah
Oh
Earlier before it was recent. I wish I would sell our bathwater and pee. I
Don't know about the pee ready
I want to be like that bell delphine
Do you guys hear that her like bathwater contain none of her like actual bathwater?
I know it's crazy. I was really offended when I got it and I smelled it and it smelled nothing like her
I
Was so thrown off by the whole like bathwater thing that I forgot to press space bar
It's okay
Yeah, we're back here
Who's stopping me the FDA? That's who's stopping me from selling my bathwater
Yeah, I was like also like you can't do that. I mean they can't catch you
They don't know if it's really on the gingerbread man
Yeah, exactly
It doesn't have to be from me being in the bath. It could just be from my bathtub
No, it's crazy. I I knew someone who genuinely bought her bathwater
And like his
All right, so I bought the like bathwater and his girlfriend like broke up with him. Yeah
Yeah, I mean he's not drinking my bathwater. He's drinking some other bitches bathwater
His girlfriend is like a like also like a Belle Delphine fan
But she was like she was she she was
Explain it
But she yelled so she didn't get it, but he did
No, she because he bought it using the money for like her anniversary present
Oh, yeah, no, there we go. There were layers to this
Oh ready go
Okay, okay
He he didn't he used the fund from that and she she broke up with him
Wait, so he was saving up money for her anniversary present and instead used it for Belle Delphine bathwater
Yeah, he he yeah
And then he like he handed it to one because he bought like multiple
He did uh, he's like here's your fucking
He thought that he thought that she would want to see me because she's you know by icon
And she was like I like Belle Delphine, but I don't want her bill her bathwater and she like broke up with him
And he he he he asked me about it. I just wouldn't want her for a present for anniversary present that just
It's okay, we got this we got this okay, I'm just gonna shut up and lock in
We gotta log in
Okay gamers silence
Oh
No, I was on it. I was on it. I was on it. No
See I locked in I was the only one left standing that was Viv's fault. She should have done that
What are you talking about? I didn't do anything. I mean, you didn't make in me laugh. We would have been fine
Chat chat. Did I do anything wrong? Yes
Chat say she did everything wrong. This tell her it's all her fault. She's been a bad girl
Help I'm falling
Okay
How did that how did I get knocked off because tech tech tech tech tech tech tech? Okay, it's okay. We can we can wait
Oh, and I have a member stream at 8 8 8 8 p.m
Uh-oh, I mean you in the same time zone
Eastern time
Beech curse, baby
No
Last attempt last attempt then look at his fine ass right there. He's flexing it. It's pretty flat
I like my ass is a little more looking at right now
No, the statue's ass
We're trying to clutch up right now
Whoa
You told me to look at his ass
You took so long. You took so long. Why do you use my full government name every single time?
Because I like saying your name. It's actually really appealing to say it for me
I like to say soprato soprato. It's like I'm stimming to my word
It's like singing keys in front of you
You can say my name if we make it
Okay, as a treat. All right, daddy
Okay, baby girl. Why do you want me to call you? Can you meow for me kitten?
Meow
Wait, we weren't ready. Don't go yet. Don't go yet. Don't go yet. Okay, ready. Who just used that voice changer. Yeah
Sorry, uh-oh, I'm just really nervous right now. I get so nervous
I get so nervous around cute girl. It's so hard. It's so hard. It's so hard
Oh, no, this is a hard one. Oh, no, it's okay. This is the last one. This is a hard one
Oh my god
We did it. Oh, yeah, that was easy. Oh my god. Why is it even sweating?
Yeah, baby
Call my name now. Come on, you kitten
Say come on say it
Come on pookie. Say my name
What?
Wait, what is that white woman jump scare voice? Can you do that again?
My white white woman jump scare voice. That's my normal voice. What are you talking about?
No, I want to hear it. Say it again. It's like an advertisement voice. Yeah
Oh
Now that you got now, I'm blushing. I can't do it do it do it
Because I'm very impressed with your voice acting skill and I want to be able to copy it
You twilight sparkle voice go I am not doing the twilight sparkle do it
Oh my god, I just realized your hair is exactly like twilight sparkle. Let's do the twilight sparkle boy
My eyes you're literally twilight sparkle. Please. Please. Don't make me do this. I'm on my hands with me
We're gonna stand here
I don't think I can do it right now. Say hi. My name is twilight sparkle and I'm the princess of friendship
My name is twilight sparkle and I'm the princess of friendship
You've done the boys. Don't make me pull up your
I'll pull up your file
You know what you're doing
You don't you don't have shit
I find worse
You'll find me talking about warwick and how much I want him to fill me up with his pups
You're the twilight sparkle boy and I'll play dead by daylight with you
Oh
I can't do it right now. I'm serious. I can't do it right now
Okay, what's another voice you can do? I'm very interested in your voice acting skill. Please. I I'm I'm I'm I'm hyper fixated now
My white woman voice
Do the white woman voice then
It's like it comes out when it comes out. She comes out
The white woman within me
Okay, let's talk about MLMs right now then guys
You know what love males
Are you talking about male pregnancy right now?
Multi-eleven all marking
My mom's old boss fell for it and went bankrupt. Oh my god. Oh my god. That's crazy
I know male pregnancy is kind of hard
What male love monday male love monday. Yeah
Male love monday
I'm talking to all the males
In the audience you want to hear about a yowie I was reading recently
Sure, it's because we're talking about MLMs right now. Yeah, where do we go this way?
Up towards the sword. I think we go. Oh a sword. Oh or we can go up. Oh
Oh, yeah, yeah, I mean he's doing something is this is right now
We can avoid the sword. I don't
There we go. I'll give you my sword. I don't get it. That's the sword man
Walk I was reading a yowie recently
And it was so it was about this like kind of like a pretty boy
And then um
There's a delinquent boy and they were childhood friends
With this one guy who's like the honorable student, but they all go to different oh my god
I know what you're talking about and I read this and they're like they're like
You're you're uh, are you at top or bottom and they just like a mega verse shit. No, no
Are you an alpha or an omega?
They are you top or bottom and then they you know, you don't pull me up. Just keep going. Just keep going. That's fine
No, I think I'm there. Oh
Amy jump off the other side
What are we doing now?
Wiggle
Just swing just start swinging
It's working
Oh, it's actually kind of working. You're right. Hold on
That's like one of those toys where you have to like avoid touching the edge or you'll get shocked. Hold on. I'm getting it
I'm getting it actually
What the fuck?
Yeah, it's working. It's working. How is she not falling off?
Because we're geniuses our brain. Okay. Oh, well, I'm not gonna swing then because I don't want to accidentally swing her off
What
I got her. Hello. Wait, you could probably teleport us back there. Oh, yeah
I
Did good, okay
Okay, let me go first. Hold on. Let me go first. Let me go first. Let me go first. Let me just jump on
Okay
Oh
I told you
All right, it's fine. Just swing on the other side. Okay, everyone pick a side. Hold on. Hold on. Let me swing across
So I can get onto this wall
You just keep falling. It's so close. It's because I'm falling for you. I don't know what to say. I just I'm just so in love
Yeah
Let me see if I can look at what I did before the riz master. Oh, no, I can't
It's more like a double day
Okay, okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. She we do still want to go first. Okay. Hold on locked in locked in locked in
Walking in I fell
Smash w
It's like I'm gonna smash her mom
Making fun of how we walked earlier now. She's doing
Yeah
Hey, if you can want to smash I'm all in now speed up gas pedal
I'm sorry
Right in my mouth, please. Oh
I changed my man
happy
Oh, we're we're doing so good right now
Don't say that as I fucking fall off and kill us all
I'll catch you
We're doing much better than I thought we would yes because we're doing the the
I accidentally hit my mic
Last time I played with bibb, she like
I'll tap forward right away
Really, why do you make it sound like I give up? I'm not a giver of her
All right, I gotta go. I really don't want to but I gotta go spend time with
Okay, wait, can we save this can we save and retry another time? Yeah, it says save and quit game
So I'm guessing oh we could do it another time you guys want to schedule it for some time in the future. Sure sure
That was fun
It's like we had a podcast as we're like in hell
Okay, let's serve podcast. Okay, well we'll message and we'll figure out when we're all free again
Mm-hmm
Okay, thank you for playing with me
Thank you so much. Bye guys. Bye guys. Thanks for providing me
Okay
We're all still here in the room
I should lick them. Hold on
Who should I make out with let's do all of them
One after another so I'll be first ready
Ah
Oh, shit. Uh, no Sophie. Sophie's the only one left
Let's go check out share. Okay. Bye Sophie here. Mwah. Okay
Oh, how do I leave?
Quit to laugh. There we go
All right, I'm gonna go to just chatting
All right, hi I was crying the whole time. Um
Um, okay
I had to turn off my crying
There we go
I was laughing so hard I was laughing too
I'm a little bit worried that the stream was like hella blurry though because that game is like kind of realistic looking
You're really good at this. I'm impressed. Oh, thank you
Honestly, I did better than I expected
I guess I didn't really have any expectations going in
Why is this virtual camera on I didn't really have too many expectations going in but
I did do pretty okay
Pretty pretty not have bad not have bad for not being a gamer. Oh my god. The game was so blurry. Are you kidding me?
Man, I'm trying to figure out how to stream with like not having a blurry game
But I think I don't know if it's possible for all games
It
I'll ask she be later. I don't know pretty okay. You took them into your backpack
The game wasn't blurry for me if you're on a phone, maybe it wasn't too blurry, but if you're on pc you're like
Oh my god, do I need glasses?
Anyway, it's fine. I'm just a little bit of a perfectionist when it comes to that sort of stuff
Is she be still streaming? Oh, she's talking
She be it has to go because she has a member stream. She was doing three times today. Can you believe that?
She basically streamed all day
I don't have the energy for that
Uh, oh i'm in the game alone save and quit quit
Also while I was playing I had opened my bedroom door
Um because it gets really hot in my bedroom
And I had the I had my apartment door open because it gets really hot in my apartment
And fucking my rats escaped my bedroom. I forgot that they were out
In fact, I'm gonna try to put them back in the cage right now. Hold on
If I can if I can get the other one in I might be able to like yap a little more
Because I can leave my door open
But like they literally could have just left and gone outside if they wanted to
If they wanted to they could have just gone outside. I had the door open
They could have been free rats. I'm trying to look around for them. Well, there's only one left this system
I think the only one left is pixie
Oh, she be rated yay. Oh fuck. Is her name yay or yay?
Oh, I'm guessing it's yay
Oh, I'm so sorry
Bro, she's got amazing tits though
One second, sorry. I'm like walking around
um
All these jack-o-lanterns reminding me of halloweep season starting it is starting soon, but for us it's always halloween season
They know they have it good no reason to leave true
I mean, they did leave my my room, but they didn't leave my um, I should turn the background music on
They left my room, but they didn't leave my apartment
Which they could have if they wanted to I guess
but
They're really scared leaving my room in general
So for Dennis
Day by day we approach closer to spooky season. Yeah, I'm really excited for spooky season. We have some fun stuff
planned for spooky season
I'm just watching yeah, I stream now
Ah
That's generally don't like new things or environments. That's true. They're they're kind of scaredy cats
And if I can get my last ratty in the cage
Let me see if she's under my bed hold on
Oh
That's where she's not under my bed. I don't know where she could be there's not a lot of hiding places in my room anymore
I used to have a closet I used to have two closets in my room one like the apartment came with like a
Like a closet built into the bedroom, but it's so so tiny that like
like you can't even walk into the closet basically like
Because it's so small right it's not a walk-in closet, but it's also like
You can't you can't go into the closet and then close the door behind you. It's so tiny
um
So I was like let me get an external closet
And then when I had that external closet bro, the rats made it their freaking home
That closet belonged to the rats. It was the rats closet
And I got rid of it simply because they kept going in there and just like fucking it up
Chewing on my clothes, pissing on my clothes
Bringing their toys in there bringing random shit in there toilet paper
I don't know what other stuff bedding
So I had to get rid of it and now there's nowhere for them to hide
Immediately made a tom and jerry mouse hole
What do you mean my rats it's a rat hunt it is
Can rats has a little cheeseburger as a treat no
No, I mean sometimes when I eat fast food I give them leftovers, but usually I don't
Usually I don't
I
Just because it's very bad for them, I mean it's bad for us too, but
I care more about the rats than me and also it tastes good. So whatever. I'm here for I'm here for uh
I'm here for a good time not for a long time
I
When do you think the cover with kaifu will be out? That's a good question. Let me check twitter
I um
I still have a couple of edits that need to be done
for the video
So it really just depends on
Really just depends on the editor. They haven't really responded to my
Adjustments, so I'll have to wait for them. Um, so I can't really tell you
When but I'm hoping really soon because everything is done. I just need to have the edits on the um
On the video done and that's pretty much it
We eat the food that's bad for us by choice we decide what our pets eat
True they would probably eat food that's bad for them too if they could decide
But they can't because I feed them because I'm their overlord
Yeah
Yep
Did you catch up on all your audios for the month for this month?
Yeah, I had them done like two weeks ago
Um
I don't believe that I have the ones I don't believe I have the scripts for october yet. Um, let me check
No
No, I don't see the scripts for october yet, so I can't start on october you epi. I'm always epi
I'm always epi
Oh, thank you for the kit that attend gifted membership. So, uh, thank you. Thank you yogi
Can you leak what they are or is I don't know?
um
I I don't know
I guess
Yeah, we we put we put schedules. We used to what we sometimes put when Madison has time to make schedules
We put schedules out. So, um
Yeah, I can tell you what it is for this um
For september uh script one is
Uh wait, maybe I can't say it on youtube exactly. Should I like censor it for youtube? Um
Rat wants to dom you
Um
Uh, the second one is called flat chested friction. I'm sure you can it's uh
The
By zootie
But without the boobs
Nice zootie. Yeah
There you go. That's what it's called. Um, the script three is under the foot of the mafia. I actually liked that one
I thought it was kind of fun. I liked the recording that one. Um,
I feel like I'm really good at acting like
An annoying rich girl
So I played as like the daughter of the mafia boss in that one. I feel like I I played that off pretty good
Petan zootie chat cheese size zootie. Yeah
Um, and the last one is just gamer girlfriend wants attention this one. I um, I think this is the only girlfriend one that was
For this month or no flat chested friction had girlfriend. I remember editing the last one though
I think I edited the last one to be a little bit more. Lovey-dovey
And also, oh my god. I have to change some of it. Let me let me just
Let me just read to you
I it's not in the script anymore. I removed it, but let me just read to you some of this stuff
Oh, thank you
I can't really um put those on patreon, but I can do like someone youtube every once in a while
The giggle sticks returns literally um
I
Man, it's not
If you want it, then you'll have to take it, but you already knew that frick use my face like a rented
Badussy go on baby. You're my little you're my freaking little winner. This is the winner of a winner
This is your throat coated in your
Gum pour it down my throat like a chug jug gum for me
gum for me
Pour it down my throat like a chug jug
I didn't say that I I couldn't I couldn't say that
um
The winner of a winner
Um, most of it was okay though
Most of it was okay. I think
There was another part that was funny though
Let me find it
Oh, I hear you eating combos up there
Is my sloppy making you sloppy is my fallatio getting you ratioed is my good head making you bad and dead
I
Think I cut up a little bit of that too
Is my fallatio getting you ratioed
No, there was no monkey noises in this one
But yeah, there was a lot of like gamer references that I didn't really understand
in these scripts
Like I I don't know what game it seems pretty obvious what game um the listener was playing
But I don't know. I don't know what it is. What are these rhymes? He's trying to be a rapper
Is this the censored version? Yeah, I had to censor it a little bit
Someone give the script writer a raise
I'm not sure about that
I'm not sure about that but like there was like a
There was like a grand theft auto
Reference in in the jeep in the mafia boss one and I was like what the fuck does who who?
Who I had to look it up
Which fun fun announcement
um
We're going to be uh, well not we
Me I'll I'll only announce me. I'm not gonna announce anyone else, but I
and maybe someone else
Are going to be
Playing grand theft auto soon now. Don't don't get don't don't worry. It's not the grand theft auto server that um everyone was playing earlier
It's a different one for girls only
And I was looking through the server and it's like oh my god. There's so many there's so many like
Cool girls here
Which I'm a little bit
Some of them. I'm like wait. Are you guys allowed to be here with us?
Like I thought you hated us, but some of them. I'm like really excited to to play with
um
So I don't know we'll see we'll see um we'll see what happens, but like
Yes, it'll be a roleplay server
I don't know how to roleplay and I've never played gta, but um
I'm excited
Hopefully I'm allowed to say that. I don't know did I ruin the surprise. I mean I didn't say much about it
It might not even happen. I don't know
Forget what I said. I didn't say anything. I didn't say anything
Um, oh my god. Sorry. I'm just like seeing the names of who joined and I'm like getting excited
I know her
I
Sorry, I'm gonna take she be real quick
Okay, anyways
Well, let me see the one gta 5 line. I don't know what line you're talking about
It's probably fine. What is the server you're roleplaying right now. No, I'm not
But um
I'm excited. I've never played gta before the only time I've ever
Like interacted with gta was when I went over to my cousin's house and um
He was playing gta
And he was like, hey watch this watch. We were like fucking eight and he was like, hey watch this watch this
And so he presses something on the on the controller and it starts to buzz and I see like giggling or I hear giggling or something
On the tv and um, and he gives me the controller to hold it as it's buzzing and I'm like
What's happening? What's what why is the controller buzzing and he's like
And I was like, oh and then I laughed a little bit
Oh
That's the one time I played
um
Yeah, that's the one but that's the one time I played um grand theft auto which one
Beats me. I don't know
The one that was out like years and years and years and years and years ago. I don't know
We're getting in me and gta before gta
Is that gta 6?
No way no weighing. I don't know roman numerals
I don't know them
Yeah
Over a decade. Oh, maybe
No, no, no, no, it definitely wasn't that one. No, no, no, no. Yes, that's six. Okay. Thank you
Was he black white or eastern european who the character? I don't remember
I don't know
Do you realize how little that narrows down? No
No
I don't
I
Don't
Oh, we're almost at 47 k how exciting and 47 k is almost at 50 k how exciting
Hold on I have to do you want to delete do you want to delete comments with me?
I
Don't think I have uh, I don't think I have enough
Comments to delete how to use it from channel bro
Can you please say they not he thinks?
Oh, that was on a ASMR of mine. Um
No
Go look for f4a
We should delete comments together here here here. I'll try deleting some
No
No, there's not really enough to delete before
I could have like saved up comments for like three days and I'd have like a hundred to delete with you
Amy censorship. Yeah, of course. I delete comments all the time. I get really shitty comments
Of course, I'm gonna delete them on the short on videos on anything
Um
I'm gonna delete this one too. Hey
That one's a weird one
Okay, I'm gonna delete that one too. It's mostly people like telling me what to do for some reason
Um about anything like I get a lot of comments like stream on twitch
stream on twitch
Like you should stream on twitch. I recommend you stream on twitch. Why aren't you streaming on twitch? Um
I get a lot of comments like um
Oh, uh like on my ASMR roleplays there's people like um
So this makes me uncomfortable to listen to can you please change the pronouns?
Can you please redo the video with like different pronouns and it's like
I I delete those ones because like you can you can find videos with different pronouns
You can find them
easily
Very easily. Well, you could probably just search up like
You could search up like a lesbian audio roleplay like why are you asking me to redo the video?
Yeah, it's a lot of back seating strangely. Um
Some people being like, oh, this is gross, which is fine. Um
That one is to be expected, but I just I didn't expect so much back seating, you know, why so much back seating?
Pair dude to me specifically
Twitch is overrated. Uh, it's not terrible. Um
It's not terrible. I just don't like
um
I don't like the split the split is bad and um
Like I feel like they have a lot of good um like streaming
Activities, I don't know what to call it like add-ons
I'm a girl, but I like the male POV
You can like whatever you want. It's just the comments that say hey, can you make this in a different POV that are like
No, but you can go look up different different ones that are for you. Um
They're they're quite easy to find
um, yeah, like the fleet the features on um
The features on twitch like the the channel points. I really enjoyed channel points
I had a lot of fun channel point channel point stuff that I I just uh, I don't have anymore
like, huh
And I wish I could find a way to is soppy still streaming. No soppy's done
Sorry
Oh, she didn't even stream on youtube did she? Oh, she didn't stream it on youtube
I don't know
um
I had one where I could like have you um
Make me talk in a British accent
in a
In a like a cowboy western accent Texan accent
I had like
Those those those those like throwing things. What are they called like a twitch interactive
Throwing system something like that where you could like throw shit at the vtuber. That's fun
I liked that. I had like head pat redeems. Those were fine. I want to be head padded again
Hold on
like
Chat can't even head pat me anymore
Can I make the animation at a higher fps? Hopefully not
Here there you go
Now chat can head pat me a little more
The twitch chat is incredibly spamming with too many emotes more often than not
Look at my chat right now. There's so many emotes. There's nothing wrong with emotes. I don't care if people spam emotes
um
Oops, sorry. I I got big
Can you do the southern accent now? No
I'm really bad at it. I'm really bad at both accents, but that's what made them funny, you know
The emotes. Yeah, they have animated emotes too, which is really cool
I wish we had animated emotes. I literally I uh, I commissioned um
I commissioned an animated emotes for the pin pals and I can't even use it
I'll just have to post it on twitter and let you guys use it if you want. It's really cute. I think you guys will like it
I think you guys will like it. It's really funny
You know british accent is surprisingly good, bro. I've had real british people be like what the fuck is that accent?
It's bad
Thank you for the the head pads. I had to give them to myself, but it's okay
Yeah, and twitch has a lot of like games that are built in to interact with your twitch chat too
and I think those are fun like um
Like cult of the lamb
You can like have your your chat like either help you or you know, um
What's it called uh sabotage you I think right like that's fun
Overall the viewer experiences way better on twitch the chat is much better and differently from youtube
You can use emotes from channels you're sub to in every channels chat. Yeah, that's cool too
Real british people exist. Yes
I'm a real british people
And I think it's a lot better than most british accents I've heard online really
Why thank you
Um, does marbles on stream work on youtube? I don't know. I don't know
I don't know. I never played marbles on stream. Well, I tried playing it once, but I couldn't figure out how to get it to work
So for being such a big company youtube streaming surprisingly shit, it's just not
It's just not um
Interactive with chat that's all it's like they don't it's on the back burner for them. They don't really care
to um
Make it better. I think
and that's you know
the issue
They don't really care to improve on it whereas twitch is all streaming. So it's like
You would hope that they would be better at it, you know
But youtube is more just for videos. That's what they focus on
you know
Um, actually if you start off as a sheep in the cult of the lamp
The bit rate and viewing experience on youtube is better. I know the viewer interaction is better on twitch. My bit rate is always shit
My bit rate always looks like shit most of the time
If i'm playing a game that's like a little bit nice graphics, it looks poop. I don't know how to fix it
YouTube doesn't care enough. They could easily outcompete twitch if they wanted to yeah, they don't care enough. It's me
It's okay. I'm not here to
I'm not here to um
Try to make a change in youtube. I don't care. I don't care. There goes my hair clip
Which operates at a massive loss so youtube probably won't care to catch up to twitch
Oh, is it because it's owned by amazon amazon likes to operate businesses at a loss don't they?
But they take 50 percent. Where is that money going?
Like 50 percent of revenue is really really high
like genuinely like
like
company vtubers that stream on twitch like
They must be making like 25 percent of their income or something like that's really really high
This is why I do all my streaming on omegle. This is why I do all my streaming on facebook streaming
I don't know facebook live
Instagram reels all my streams will now be on instagram guys
To the ceo. Oh, that's why they operate as uh with a loss because all the money is just going back to the ceo
A really weird keep up thor did a breakdown of how much one stream for them costs and it's very weird
Oh, well do it better
I don't know
Do it better. I'm sure they could figure out a way to make it better
My favorite feature of twitch is the emotes of channels you become a member of can be used in other channels
Yeah, I really like that too. I really like that too
But I guess here you can't do it
I don't know if youtube operates at a loss to be honest. I don't know
I don't know anything about these businesses
Okay
This is now this is epic. Also a lot of people say I sound like marceline
Do I sound like marceline? No one in real life has ever ever ever told me I sound like marceline
Oh
It's gonna get copyrighted isn't it
It's awesome
Being read all down the produce aisle. It was awesome. I don't think I sound like marceline
I
Kind of
Oh no, man, the shrimp must have gone bad or something because all that red came right back up
Still invisible and yacking red all down the produce aisle. It was awesome
Not really don't think so can't tell
Kind of almost
Kind of sort of I don't think okay, it seems like I'm getting a lot of mixed uh mixed answers
That girl in the beginning
Princess bubblegum or
I don't know who the character was
That's marceline just looks weird
I think it's the vocal fry maybe uh, I don't know why I have that. I don't know why I have that
It just comes naturally to me
I sound like the grudge
Similar inflections but not the same sound more God
I
Wow a woman
That doesn't sound super high pitched mommy sorry mommy
Please let me suck on your tiggly winks. Oh mommy, please. Oh
Mommy, please. Let me put my face in between your badonka dunks and jiggle it around. Please. Let me feel my mommy, please
It's like you're burping in slow motion
You
Sound like a japanese horror movie girl. Yeah, that's the grudge is it not the grudge
What happens after that doesn't get said on youtube. Thank you mommy. Oh my gosh. Thank you mommy. Oh
I don't know I don't know what sound fat makes when it jiggles around clap clap clap clap
That's a perfect clip clip it then
Plop plop plop plop
Maybe a little bit of shlurpin
I'm sorry. I should watch adventure time again. I really like adventure time
I see that as if I haven't watched it like 10 times already
I watched adventure time a lot. It's a really big uh
comfort show for me
and I don't know why
Um what the sigma any ideas when the ada ada short would be going up? I think usually it takes about a week for
My shorts to get edited but sometimes it can take longer than a week. Um
It's really bad though. I don't really like like people assume that I can do it well, but I can't I I really can't and
I think I might even delete it if it doesn't get popular because I
Actually hate it so much
Like it's actually really really cringe and I like I know it's cringe like I know people will find a cringe. Um
And I know it doesn't sound good
But I'm trying to be like oh, maybe other people will think it sounds good and then it'll get popular
Because obviously it's me. I don't think anything I say sounds good, but other people do
So if I try saying ada ada, maybe they'll like it even if I don't you know like I know it's cringe
That's why I'm like if this doesn't get popular. I might just delete it because it's too cringe
I don't want to embrace the cringe. It's really cringe
I like
Adventure time watch along. Uh, I don't know. I just I don't like watch alongs too much
I know you say you like it
I'll play on repeat just so you don't delete it do it do it
If you don't want me to delete it then then get that short popular and then I won't delete it
I'll just to see that all the hate comments I get but I'll keep it up
Let me see if I can find it. I'll listen to it myself and see if I if I cringe or not
Um, I'm gonna mute the audio so you can't hear it though
Because it's surprise for you
Hey home here I go here I go
I'm prepared
Oh
Oh, it's bad. It's bad. I can't give you a sneak peek. It's just two words
You want me to give you like the first zero point zero one millisecond of the first add up like
There is no sneak peek. It's just two words
Speaking of popular 500k on that one short is it insane it is it is I
I
Don't know why that happened, but it is
um, I appreciate people that you know
Um watched it and subscribed and were respectful about it
Just say ah, ah
There you go
For it not to be cringe you got to own it you got if you don't own it
It will be cringe if I show you what it sounds like. Will you will you be honest and tell me if it's cringe or not?
Because I feel like you won't that's the thing like I don't know I don't know who to show it to for them to be like
Super honest with me. Like I need you to hurt my feelings, you know
Like I need you to like literally slap me across the face and spit in my mouth and grab my hair and throw it
Force it into the dirt and like
Scream at me to never say that ever again
like
I feel like people aren't honest enough with me because they um, they don't want to hurt my feelings
But like I want you to hurt my feelings
Do you know what I mean?
So that way I know that it's bad and I don't do it again because like
I know that it's bad, but I'm I'm wondering if other people
Think it's bad, you know
I'm I'm just talking in a circle at this point
I have been honest always people are not honest. That's what I'm saying. They're not
They're not honest and that's why it's like
I don't I was already cringe by default. I can't laugh it is that's what I'm saying
It is cringe and it took me so many tries to say it too
It took me so many tries because I kept cringing and I'm sure I've I've done better takes of it while I was trying
But I just kept cringing and I was like no I can't do it. I can't do it
Delete that one. Let me try again and then I eventually just landed on
The one I have in the audio
But it's cringe like just just naturally it is cringe, you know
Y'all are saying you'll be honest, but I know you lie. You lie
Some people have very very different tastes. What's cringe to some is not to others
I know
I don't know
I
Just can't tell if you always want us to be honest because sometimes if you say
To not be honest like to say something is good. Anyways, if that makes us if I tell you to say something is good
Then yes, of course say it's good
I mean look at us. We're all cringe. I know
but um
Enjoyed this dream in background while working on controllers thx for being here pumpkin
Oh
Thank you. I'm glad you enjoyed it
I'm the same way, which is why I'm so honest. I'd rather get told I'm cringe than get lied to no sometimes
I want you to lie to me sometimes
Sometimes I
Sometimes I want you to lie to me, okay?
When I tell you to lie to me lie to me, but when I tell you to be honest to me be honest to me
It's pretty simple. It's pretty simple. Okay
You ever get tired of speaking in your high voice? No
Unless I'm sick or depressed as fuck
then yes
um
I respect you too much not to be honest with to you, but some people don't
Also, some people are just too nice in general, you know
Yes, just listen to what I tell you to do. It's not complicated. Oh, it's very simple
It's so simple. It's not complicated. I don't know why you think it's complicated
It's so simple
We walk a thin line with all the flip-flop like just just
Just do what I tell you to okay
It's really not that hard
Listen to what I say and do it
Understood
We won't lie you just don't want us to say we like it so you won't do it again jokes
But I promise I'll be honest with this
I'm scared. I'm too nervous. You'll see when it comes out. You'll see when it comes out
Let let the editor do it that way when you when you see it um in your in your um
subscription feed you'll be like, oh, this is the one that Amy talked about and then
I want to need water
You'll be like, oh my god, this is the one that Amy talked about and then you'll be um
Curious and then you'll watch it and that'll help boost the video and then yeah
Yeah
Yeah, and you can tell me in the comments if it's cringe you can be like Amy
I'm so sorry, but straight up this is cringe like
Don't ever don't ever cook again. Amy. Don't ever cook again. Get out of the kitchen
Let's all request a part two so Amy knows we love it
Of ara ara, what's another thing that mommy say ora ora I bark like dingy when the note of hints
Go ahead. I want to hear it record you barking proof
Cooked a little too hard this time
I cooked so hard that the kitchen like
Caught on fire and the whole the whole building is being evacuated
And people are coughing at the this the smell of smoke from my cooking
What do mommy say I don't know what do mommy say
It's like the brain rot stream you did please never do another one of those I won't do another one of those
I'm I'm glad people told me that they were that that it was bad
I also thank you for the $10
Try the yada yada does it what does that mean?
I thought they just yelled at you to do your homework
Your room is disgusting
clean your room
You know I came here two weeks ago, and it actually looked worse than it is no hillan. I don't know how to sound like a
I came in here two weeks ago, and it actually looked nice what happened. I cleaned your room
Why can't you keep it clean your laundry is all over the floor
Your trash is overflowing
You got you got red bull cans all up under your all up under your bed and on your desk
I should have swallowed you
You should have gone in my asshole and stayed there and died in there
I should have wiped you off my boobs that's where you should have gone into the trash afterwards
The brain rot stream was so painful it was the most fun I had in a while it was just bad
I had fun because we got to sing a little bit, but it was bad
Yeah, I made you lose some brain cells with that one for sure
Scream it so it feels real what do you want me to scream I should have swallowed you
I should have swallowed you I already did disappointed mom
ASMR with kaifu I guess it wasn't exactly disappointed mom
It was it was um divorced ASMR, but it was basically disappointed mom at the end
I guess kaifu was a disappointed mom
There's other divorced ASMR and it's actually like pretty popular
Oh ours shows up pretty quick. Maybe because no, it's probably because I'm subscribed to kaifu
Abusive mommy ASMR no, I'm not gonna I'm not gonna do that
Absolute cinema, I don't remember that one. I didn't post it on my channel
I'm sorry for yawning. I don't know why I'm yawning. I was yawning so much
I was yawning so much during our collab too
Me and your mom are getting a divorce ASMR
Ex-husband regrets asking for divorce something I never understood about a lot of a lot of
Like okay, I like a lot. Okay. It's embarrassing. I listen to boyfriend ASMR sometimes
Um, something I don't understand about a lot of boyfriend ASMR. Why?
Why do they
Why do they make the most unhinged content? It'll be like
Boyfriend slaps you and then cries in your arms and asks for forgiveness and asks you not to leave him
Boyfriend fucking aborts your unborn baby and then cries in your arms and asks you not to leave
Boyfriend burns your house down
And argues with you that it was your fault and it's not even the meme ones
That's like I'm not referencing the meme ones. I'm actually talking like about real ones like real like genuinely like
Genuine ones that are supposed to be serious. You know
Somebody out there isn't it like like literally like
Abusive alcoholic boyfriend begs you not to leave him like stuff like that. Hold on
Like you can just search up like
Abusive boyfriend ASMR and you'll get like a shit ton of them
Abusive boyfriend controlling and manipulating you 100k views
Like there's just like full on serious abusive boyfriend content. That's just how men are
like
Why abusive boyfriend with anger issues goes off on you
There's so many and they're all so popular like
Like do some women just want to be yelled at and not in a sexy way
you know
like not in a sexy way just like
Just in a mean way like straight up just I hate you
Crazy boyfriend fights over dirty dishes
Oh
My god boyfriend just checks on your phone
Evil dad tries to get rid of you that stuff too. That's too like
We're all just freaks
Boyfriend is emotionally manipulative and begs you to stay with him. Yeah show us you can just look it up
Like it's not even is this some sort of male yandere? No, it's not even it's not even tagged as yandere
like
I like yandere like I like the toxicity of yandere, but this is just not even
like a hot
Like it's just mean like some people just like and also there's ones where it's like, um
I don't know like like
boyfriend fights you after you tried to kiss your sister
Like what like I know people. Okay. I know people some people need something like that, but also like the fact that
It's a thing is so strange to me. I don't know
Amy have you seen book talk that should not be super I have seen
I am on book talk. Where do you think I get my book recommendations? I get a lot of them from book talk
I'm on book talk
I am part of book talk
That's kind of along the lines of how netorata is so popular
People just like being like straight up
like
bullied I guess
But it's not even I don't know. I guess I just don't understand it
I guess I just don't understand it
What's book talk b b o okay
t okay for tick talk. It's the book side of tick talk
We want to see any specific wrecks. I've told you my favorite book before but I think no one paid attention to it
So now no one knows
You don't know
Yeah, y'all never know
horror horror
What scenarios do you like best when you look for boyfriend ASMR like
Do you want it to be more comfy with the yandana stuff as well? Yes for sure comfy
I don't like it when there's like a lot of stuff happening
um
I know I've made audios where like a lot of shit is happening
But that's because I'm just a bad writer and I I'm like I ran out of ideas
So I'm like I need something to happen, but I don't like it when there's like a lot of stuff happening
I like something casual, you know
I'm in casual
Any kind of radiates book talk energy
I don't know what that means, but I am on book talk
Is it like when people read books on tick talk no not really it's more like
It's more of people like reading books like reviewing books recommending you books, you know being like
Here are the top 10
spiciest
Romance novels I've read in the last I don't know six months or something. Um
Stuff like that
I
They say are a summer's wide wild the stuff the ladies like is wild. I know both sides are wild both sides have really wild stuff
I listen to your favorite songs and they were interesting to say the least
Thank you
I don't know
I have do I have more favorite songs? I don't know my favorite songs
Are kind of all over the place
Let me look up on my spot if I there are mommy and that is if that makes it better for you for me
For me
There's daddy on that is too
Sorry, I'm sniffling. I don't know why
What are your favorite bands? I don't have any actually
I
Don't like old songs. Not really. No, sometimes I'll find one that I like but most of the songs I like are pretty
New pretty new
When do you have time to read between sleeping doing ASMR and streaming me?
um, I'm trying to slow down
It's it's hard to say this I'm trying to slow down because like
I'm really bad at managing the content I want to make so
As much as I want to get stuff done
I'm like so bad at managing that I end up procrastinating and not getting stuff done anyways
So I'm trying to slow down and hopefully I'll be able to like
If I have less plans to do
Then I will hopefully do it, but I'm not even doing much anyways in the first place
I'm not even doing much anyways. Like I'm doing nothing
I am literally most of the time doing nothing. So it's really hard to say like, oh, yeah, I'm actually gonna be doing less
I'm gonna be doing less than nothing
Yeah, um
But I'm still planning to record a video like an ASMR video this week
um
Yeah
How can a dad be a yandere?
Insects
Cool did it ASMR slept on imagine a cool chick all aloof and casual but the QC stuff comes out
As she talks to you I'd love more of that
I don't know
I
Miss want to die bro. What's wrong with miss want to die that bro that song hits so hard. I love miss want to die
It makes sense to slow down you mentioned being overwhelmed. I know but like
I'm like
Why am I even overwhelmed? I guess I'm not even overwhelmed
I'm just bad at
Being
normal
I guess
um
I caught up with you for the book club. I have to say I see why you're reacting how you did
I'm gonna get to you reading that tonight, but
Those chapters
I know I hit it hit a lot of the
Hit a lot of my um
I don't even know how to describe
Hit a lot of my funny bones my funny bones got hard. Um
Is
It like feeling is it feeling like being unorganized? Yes
Definitely definitely very unorganized. Yes. I am very unorganized
Nothing. I don't I'm not an organized person at all. No
I've I have been organized before and the times where I was my most organized
Were the times where I got the most stuff done
Not necessarily times where I felt the greatest but it's like
I don't know how to explain it
It's hard. It's hard to explain
Imagine being normal so cringe. I want to be normal. I want to be a normie
I want to be a normie that doesn't have to think about stuff
I want to be a brainless normie
You know
Sebian is still better than mallard. I know I I
I like them both equally
I need external motivation to do stuff like have someone tell me something has to get done
Yeah, I need external motivation too, but the problem is
I'm not like
I'm not always great at sticking to the external motivation, you know, especially when like
Strani is so nice. So she's never like, hey, I asked you to do this on this day, but you never did it
You know, she doesn't do that. She's just like when I the before I used to ask for
For some stuff I used to ask for deadlines, but I wouldn't always stick to them
So I felt bad continuing to ask so I stopped
Um, because she especially she's too nice. She's not like, hey
You didn't do it by your deadline
You know, she just didn't say that which is fine. She's too nice to say anything about it
So now I just don't ask for deadlines and I just I just do on my own time
Why don't we be your external motivation? We can give you that push. I feel like you're not you're not in my life
Like you have to be there constantly, you know, you have to be there constantly
I can't constantly be telling you what I'm trying to do, you know
Unfortunately, I cannot constantly be streaming and talking to you, you know
I understand how you feel
I love writing as a hobby, but I can never finish because I have so many ideas in so little time
And so little energy for me so little energy
I don't know why
Maybe I'm just not eating healthy enough. That's fair
Uh, anxiety is a big problem for me. I procrastinate about stuff that stresses me out. Um
So then it stresses me out more. I've been doing that too. Yeah, I do that a lot
A true procrastinator, you can't be given the option that it's okay
It has to be real deadline. They hold you that they hold you too. Yeah
It has to be a real real deadline like literally you fucking kick me out of the company if I can't get it done in time like
That's what I mean
Like I can't I can't just be a suggestion
Because when I was in school, they would do this stupid shit where it's like
Oh, please have it done by I don't know. Let me look at the calendar. Please have it done by Wednesday, September 4th
Right, they would be like that. They would say the deadline is Wednesday for September 4th
But
You have a 24 hour extension automatically every student is giving a 20 every student is given a 24 hour extension
automatically
And when you tell me that that just means that it's due on Thursday, September 5th
That just tells me okay, great. It's not doing Wednesday. It's due on Thursday and I'm going to be doing it on Thursday
Yeah, like what do you mean an automatic extension to every student? That's just telling me it's it's due on Thursday
So
Every time you miss a deadline you need to post it out of short. No
That would be real punishment. That would be real punishment
Has a little sister her homework today. I don't have homework. Do you want to do?
So, you know, it's really funny people thought I was acting during that one asmr stream
Where um, I was doing homework
I'm generally that bad at math and I don't I I I don't know I don't know why
Here do you want to do exponents?
Oh
That's loud I don't know I so loud
Wait, okay, hold on. It's too loud turn the volume down. Can I can I pause wait guys wait guys hold on. I'm already
Hold on guys. Okay, whatever. Sorry, uh
What?
Oh, let's go
Let's go, okay
Uh, oh, okay
Oh, wait, these are simple. Oh, oh, is it four? Okay
Um
See how it takes me a long time
See how it takes me a really long time
Don't tell me the answers. Hi, we're seeing math games online. Should I go to math games online?
cool math games
cool math games dot com
Where's the math games numbers?
Um multiplication slash division. I'm really bad at those
Math versus monsters I have to fucking watch an ad
No, it doesn't exist anymore. No, I'm on cool math games dot com right now
The speed doesn't matter it's the result even the result is bad sometimes
Let's see if this one will
All right, let me crop this out for you. I don't know why they always make the game so fucking tiny
Yeah
Um
I'll just play wait on what 12 times 12
Is it six I almost said 64. No, stop telling me the answer
Do I oh I choose which one it is right?
What what do I do here
How do I play I maybe I should have pressed how to play
All right, hold on how to play use arrow keys to move there will be a question in
The center screen go to the green door that has the right answer. Oh
Okay
Okay, okay. I saw in chat someone said it's 144. Oh, this is 64. I know this one from minecraft
Uh 32 this one I also know from minecraft
Okay, this one's easy I can do this one some of them are easy some of them are a little hard. Oh, no, I died
Bro
I can't even do the the actual
Are you kidding me? I can't even do the actual game part of cool math games
Why can't they move? Oh
Oh
Um
It's 36 right nice
This one's 16 some of these are easy. I can do some of these these ones aren't that bad
Okay, this one's obviously um, oops
This one's oh my god
This one's 80
Oh
Okay, wait when they put like small numbers and then big numbers combined. I don't know
You have to make the numbers close to each other 18 times four. I feel like I need to
This isn't good. This is too easy. This is too easy
Give me you know what maybe I am good at math
Maybe actually I am good at math. What's applied math?
I know I'm a math genius. It's just too easy for me
Now if we were to do like actual
Math homework where I wouldn't have oops
I just closed the tab accident if we were to do like actual math homework where I wouldn't have like
Possible like three possible answers
um
Shut up
When the game for dollars is too easy
Here me versus computer. I don't know how to play this one
Tap the screen to stop the dart. Well, I thought this was about math press and drag to set power and is this not about math?
I looked for math games. Oh my god. Okay. I'm gonna I'm gonna do ninth grade. Let's do ninth grade
Let's try that
Um, let's do algebra
Oh
Oh, no
Oh, no, this isn't even a game. This isn't a game. This is just a question
Okay, another thing is I learned all of my math in french, right
All of my math I learned in french. Um
So when you say the word, um
Polynomials, I'm like what the fuck is a polynomial, you know
I don't know what that means. Um, okay
I think I okay, maybe this one's too hard
Just stop giving it to I think you need like a pen and paper for this one
I'm gonna I'm gonna randomly choose one
Okay
Ah, damn it. It's incorrect
It was um negative 15. Hey, I was close. I chose C instead of D
Oh
French algebra so scary. It's not I don't know. It's just as scary as regular math
Okay, we'll stop doing math. I'm sorry
Are you smarter than a fifth grader video game? The thing is that video game
I broke down a tier seeing that that was just ninth grade. Come on
That was just ninth grade the problem with are you smarter than a fifth grader?
Is that
I'll come on you gave me the answers in this article the game. It has like really shitty reviews and everyone hates it
There's an online game um play
Do you want to play are you smarter than a fifth grader?
Oops
No, no players zero one solo
Oh, you can join me
Do you want to play are you smarter than a fifth grader together?
Oh hosts. Oh, you can only have 10. Oh
Um
Hmm
This one
Huh, oh there you go
If you want to join there's only 10 players allowed sadly so um
Number stream idea, I guess we can do this on members. We can play one round here together real quick
No one's joining guys. You don't want to join
It's a crowd party out here. It's this is the this is the website
I think
Crowd party all three players
Who the fuck is in these feet
Uh, it's okay if you're not a pc. I'll I'll probably play it again in a member stream or something similar to this
Okay
Okay questions will appear on the screen. Should I go into like my gaming?
Hold on I'll I'll play it soon. Hold on
There we go
Um
Whatever or I mean, you know, okay, let's play
Can she shut up
You
Thomas Edison Thomas Edison Thomas Edison, okay
Let's go
I don't know why it wasn't clicking for me. Can I go to next next round?
Oh man, I'm at the bottom of the leaderboard. These are easy
Excuse me, no
What
What what what the fuck? What the hell I shouldn't have accepted it. What the fuck man
Then
I don't like how it doesn't show that I've um
Um clicked that answer
Wait, am I not playing am I literally just the host right now?
Am I literally just the host right now?
Guys, please please please don't choose something stupid. These are easy
These are easy. It's a milky way
Who said the
Solar system
Could it would be better could it maybe might be better the baby
Okay
I can't see the questions wait, seriously
I made it so that you could
I thought I did at least yes, it's obviously six. There we go
It's argues more than a fifth grader not argues more than an astrophysic
Wait, I actually don't know mousses
Mousses no moose moose moose is a moose moose moose
It's moose it's moose it's moose
It's moose
I got it at the end, okay
Versions
All the ink is I don't know I I don't know anything about history
Oopsies
Okay
I
I'm gonna guess
I'm not gonna tell you my guess. I don't want you to vote for my guess until I until it's done
I'm gonna guess brazil
fuck
China
Okay, but how how are we supposed to know this stuff? Are you are you guys googling the answers?
Oh, this one's easy
I'm I I'm I what?
It's the roman empire, right?
Okay, there we go. That's easy
Okay, we have two more questions
Oh, this one's easy. I know this one
I know this one
It's fifth grade knowledge. I okay. Well my fifth grade is different than your okay. Yeah, it's a murder
Yeah
I knew that one for sure. I did I did it's a murder
Okay
Oh, it's french
Right
Yeah
Yeah, we did it. Oh wait. No, sorry. There's one more round
It's us fifth grade knowledge that uk school system is surprisingly late on american history stuff. I didn't learn any history
Oh, come on symbolism
Okay
Thank you for playing
Congratulations on winning emmy's feet
Okay, I won't um
I won't play anymore
How do I get this tab away?
Shout out to emmy's feet
Oh
Okay, uh she be streaming but it's a member stream
Let's read Ella Ella. Oh, sorry, elia
Fuck elia
Elia let's read elia
Wait, let me just make sure it's not a member stream. It is not a member stream
You got some smart tootsies. I apparently I do I had no clue that my feetsies were so smart
We did it
Oh
And then as usual I'm gonna have to copy that link just in case it doesn't go through
I hope you enjoyed our collab. I actually I think that's the most fun I've had in a collab
So far I had a lot of fun
Yeah, it's a little bit of a long stream, surprisingly, but I had a lot of fun in that collab
um
So I hope you had fun watching it. I know it was blurry, but I'll try to fix that in the future
I'm so dead
I'm gonna go eat dinner. It's just leftover food from my favorite restaurant that I got last night
um
Is it dark outside? I can't tell
Oh, yeah, it's probably dark
What kind of food I just told you it's asian food
It's really good. I love that restaurant. I'm literally I'm literally debating on ordering again from that restaurant because I love it so much
I love it so much. Literally everything I've ordered from them ever has been like a hit
And that's really rare for me because I'm a really picky eater
But like everything I've ordered from them has been a hit so I'm like
Happy because I have never found a restaurant. I like that much
um
I'll see you Wednesday for the member stream. We're gonna be taking a nap together
Now I might move the member stream um
Just be on the lookout I might move it later
just because um
like before it's really hot that day
And I don't want to be like trying to fall asleep in the heat because that's gonna be really uncomfortable
So I might move it to like a couple hours later
um
We'll see
What if I accidentally just like sleep all night?
No to to later in the day to later in the day
I'm just gonna accidentally just stream for eight hours while I'm sleeping in the bed
And I'm gonna wake up and I won't even remember that I'm still streaming you think that'd be peak
That'd be embarrassing. I probably fart in my sleep. I don't want you to hear that
Okay, okay anyways, I'll see you on Wednesday. Um, have a good night or rest of your day
Um, I'll miss you every day that I'm not streaming
I'm always like I should stream today because I miss you
But I know I know I know I shouldn't stream every day. I I can't do it
But I I'll miss you tomorrow, but I'll see you Wednesday. Okay. Bye. Bye pookie. Love you
Oh
You